Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to our second episode of The Rest Is History in our Avengers Assemble-esque crossover with Hardcore History's Dan Carlin. Now, if you haven't listened to the first episode already, just listen to the first episode. You will remember that Tom Holland and I set out to ask Dan Carlin the biggest questions in all history. Tom's were ridiculous and futile multiple choice questions. Mine were genuinely big and serious questions. And anyway, without further ado, let's get on
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的 restis》第二期节目，这是我们与“硬核历史”的丹·卡林（Dan Carlin）进行的“复仇者联盟”式梦幻联动。如果你还没听过第一期节目，去听第一期就好了。大家会记得，汤姆·霍兰和我向丹·卡林提出了整个历史长河中最宏大的问题。汤姆的问题是荒谬且毫无意义的选择题。我的则是真正宏大而严肃的问题。总之，废话不多说，我们开始吧
with it or we'll be approaching the length of one of Dan's infamous 27 hour podcasts. So Tom, the next question for Dan, please. What would you choose to be? A French nobleman born in 1330, a Lakota chieftain born in 1865, a member of the British upper classes born in 1894? Is this like a trick question? It's only my ignorance that makes me want to pick the French example because I'm trying to think what happened after 1330 that's as bad as what happens to the Lakota after the 1800s and what happens. Black Death. Oh, yes.
否则我们就快赶上丹那些长达 27 小时的臭名昭著的播客了。所以，汤姆，请问丹下一个问题。你会选择成为什么？一个生于 1330 年的法国贵族，一个生于 1865 年的拉科塔族酋长，还是一个生于 1894 年的英国上流社会成员？这难道是个脑筋急转弯吗？正是因为我的无知，才让我想要选择法国那个选项，因为我在想，1330 年之后发生的事，有什么能和 19 世纪之后拉科塔人遭遇的苦难以及发生的那些事一样糟糕。黑死病。哦，对。
Okay. Of course, it's the Black Death. I wasn't thinking continent wide. I was thinking the Hundred Years War. I was thinking the Hundred Years War. That's what I was thinking of. But the Black Death is really what's. Oh, goodness gracious.
好吧。当然，是黑死病。我刚才没从整个欧洲大陆的角度去想。我当时想的是百年战争。我当时想的是百年战争。我刚才想的是这个。但黑死病才是真正……哦，天哪。
What was the first option again? French nobleman born in 1330. Oh, what was the second option? Lakota chieftain born in 1865. A member of the British upper classes born in 1894. Oh, man. Those all suck, don't they? That was the point.
刚才第一个选项是什么来着？生于 1330 年的法国贵族。哦，第二个选项是什么？生于 1865 年的拉科塔族酋长。一个生于 1894 年的英国上流社会成员。哦，天呐。这些选项也太惨了吧？这就是重点所在。
I'm going to say the British upper classes gonna say the british upper class is uh that's the right answer isn't it i think it's got to be because i mean they don't i mean you're thinking the first world war but lots of people don't fight in the first world war okay a male a male there's lots of planners there's lots of people behind the scenes and you guys are looking at this from too too high afalutin it'sistry. This has to be decided based on the level of dentistry. It's all bad, though. It's all bad. It's not 14th century bad. I mean, Tom, surely someone like Bertie Worcester was born in 1894. Didn't George Orwell famously say that the real Bertie Worcester died in 1915?
我会选英国上流社会，我要选英国上流社会，呃，这才是正确答案，对吧？我觉得肯定得选这个，因为我的意思是，他们不用——我是说，你会想到第一次世界大战，但很多人并没有参战。好吧，一个男性的男性，有很多规划者，有很多幕后人员，而你们看待这个问题的方式太高高在上、太装腔作势了。这必须根据牙科水平来决定。不过，这些选项都很糟糕。都很糟糕。还没到 14 世纪那么惨。我是说，汤姆，像伯蒂·伍斯特这样的人肯定生于 1894 年吧？乔治·奥威尔不是说过那句名言吗，真正的伯蒂·伍斯特死于 1915 年？
I think you could have had a very different life where you you could still have gone to eton and then oxford or cambridge but then you could have spent the war throwing bread rolls at people in the drones club and doing some sort of well you could you could be invalided out and become a poet i suppose well you could be jr tolkien couldn't you you could be writing fantasy novels about a bit of winston churchill yeah absolutely you could be but tolkien i mean he lost was it, kind of three of, you know, there was a band of four friends and three of them died. That's right, but it's still better than that.
我觉得你可以过一种完全不同的人生，你可以去伊顿公学，然后去牛津或剑桥，接着你可以在无人俱乐部（Drones Club）里度过战争岁月，向别人扔面包卷，或者做一些——好吧，你可以因伤退役，然后成为一名诗人，我想。好吧，你可以成为 J·R·R·托尔金，对吧？你可以写一些关于温斯顿·丘吉尔的奇幻小说。没错，绝对可以。你当然可以，但托尔金——我是说，他失去了，是一群朋友里，有四个人，其中三个都去世了。没错，但那也比这个强。
That's a hell of a lot better than the Black Death. Or having your civilization wiped out with a Lakota. You could be Chaucer. I mean, Chaucer lived through that. When was Chaucer born? About the same time. He's not French, though, is he? No. But lots of French? About the same time. He's not French though, is he? No.
那可比黑死病强太多了。或者像拉科塔人那样，文明被彻底消灭。你可以成为乔叟。我是说，乔叟就经历过那个时代。乔叟是什么时候出生的？差不多那个时候。不过他不是法国人，对吧？不对。但是有许多法国人？差不多那个时候。不过他不是法国人，对吧？不对。
But lots of French people survived the Black Death. I think you're likelier to be killed in the trenches, if you remember. So would you... A junior British officer. Is your choice a French nobleman? I think it is, yeah. It's interesting that nobody chooses the Lakota option.
但是许多法国人在黑死病中活了下来。我觉得如果你仔细想想，你在战壕里丧命的可能性更大。所以你会……一个英国见習军官。你的选择是法国贵族吗？我想是的，没错。有趣的是，没有人选择拉科塔人的选项。
That's just unspeakably awful. Yeah, it is, isn't it? Because there you have your entire way of life destroyed as well. and if you survive it still sucks so i mean that's the difference yeah so when you're about 30 is it you're doing the ghost dance is that about right is that 1890s 1890s yeah so you've got the ghost dance to look forward to as it were yeah but then you get then you get wounded knee right afterwards right yeah it's not good is it it's bad good yeah okay that was actually quite an easy one i think it's not i think i think being a french laborer would be brilliant no especially if you're good at jousting you're gonna get killed at ashen core you are you
那简直惨得无法形容。对啊，确实如此，不是吗？因为那样的话，你整个人生方式都被彻底摧毁了。而且如果你活下来，生活依然很糟糕，所以这就是区别。对啊，所以当你大概 30 岁的时候，是要跳鬼舞吗？大概是那个时候吗？那是 1890 年代吗？1890 年代，对。所以你得期待鬼舞节的到来，可以说是这样。对，但随后紧接着就会遭遇伤膝河大屠杀，对吧？对，这可真不妙，对吧？太惨了，对，好吧，其实这题还挺容易的，我觉得。不对，我觉得当个法国劳工应该挺棒的，不，特别是如果你擅长比武竞技的话，你会在阿让库尔战役里送命的，你绝对会。
are you're gonna be killed tom when you're well i mean look at these dates you'll be killed when you're 85 yeah but you're likely you're likely to be killed in the battle of the song then you aren't you know a battle during the hundred years war if you if you had the choice of which you know would you rather fight in the first world war or the hundred years war hundred years war every time oh god i think especially if you're a nobleman because no hundred years because if you're a nobleman you're like you're going to get ransomed yeah if you live yeah that's if you're a member of the upper class you know you're you're a junior officer dan i don't know if you've noticed this, but Tom's questions come with an enormous number of caveats. So if you remember, there was that one about the siege where he would be a woman with children.
你绝对会，汤姆，当你——好吧，看看这些日期，你会在 85 岁的时候送命，对。但比起百年战争中的战役，你在索姆河战役中丧命的可能性更大，对吧？如果你有得选，你会愿意在一战中作战还是在百年战争中作战？每次都会选百年战争。天哪，我觉得特别是如果你是个贵族，因为没有——百年战争因为如果你是个贵族，你会被赎回，对，如果你能活下来，对，如果你是上流社会成员，你知道的，你是个见习军官，丹，我不知道你有没有注意到，汤姆的问题里有大量的附加条件。所以如果你还记得的话，之前那个关于围城的假设里，他会变成一个带着孩子的妇女。
This time, he would be a French nobleman. As a French nobleman, I'm going to be ransomed, whereas as a British officer, I'm going to be blown up. Well, but let's understand, though, a lot of people survived the First World War. I mean- I accept that. Including Germans. I mean, Russians. I mean, and those people took abhorrent casualties.
而这一次，他会成为一个法国贵族。作为一个法国贵族，我会被赎回，而在英国军官看来，我会被炸得粉身碎骨。好吧，但我们要明白，其实很多人都在第一次世界大战中活了下来。我是说——我接受这一点。包括德国人。我是说，俄罗斯人。我的意思是，那些人承受了骇人听闻的伤亡。
I mean, Hitler survived it. Yeah, he did. Yeah. That is true. All right. So you're both going for British member of the upper classes. I'm going for French nobleman. And none of us are going for Lakota chieftain.
我是说，希特勒都活下来了。对，他确实活下来了。没错，这是真的。好吧。所以你们俩都选了英国上流社会成员。我选的是法国贵族。而我们没有一个人选拉科塔族酋长。
No. All right. So we have another one, yeah so we have a big question a big and woolly question uh dan wouldn't we be happier if we stopped studying history oh that's an interesting line um i don't think so myself but i i have no other way to look at it. I can't imagine what it would be like to go through life not knowing this stuff. I see your point. I see the opposite of what you might expect, where people will say, gosh, I thought my life was so terrible until I studied about what it was like in the trenches of the First World War, and now I have a better perspective that my life isn't so terrible. I think that's how I look at it. Like I had mentioned the dentistry example to you guys earlier. I try to keep it real. Things like that make me appreciate my own time more and
没有。好吧，那我们还有另一个问题，对，我们有一个宏大而抽象的问题，呃，丹，如果我们不再研究历史，社会会不会更快乐？哦，这是一个有趣的观点，嗯，我自己并不这么认为，但我没有别的看法。我无法想象不了解这些东西的人生会是什么样。我明白你的意思。我看到了与你预期相反的现象，人们会说：“天哪，在研究了一战战壕里的情景之前，我一直觉得我的生活糟透了，而现在我有了更好的视角，觉得我的生活其实没那么糟糕。”我想我是这么看的。就像我之前跟你们提到的牙科例子一样。我试着面对现实。诸如此类的事情让我更加感激我所处的时代，
put it into a perspective and realize how fortunate I am. But yes, that only is reflected in the fact of how terrible the other times were. So I don't see it that way, but it depends maybe on one's personality type. But also, doesn't it depend where you are? So for example- If you're in Ukraine. Right. Or if you're in Russia, or indeed, if you're in Yugoslavia in the 1990s. I mean, there are an enormous number, I would argue, of civil wars, for example, or ethnic conflicts,
并把它放在一个宏大的视角中，让我意识到自己是多么幸运。但是，是的，这仅仅反映在其他时代是多么糟糕的事实上。所以我并不这么看，但这也许取决于个人的性格类型。不过话说回来，这难道不取决于你身处何地吗？比如说——如果你身处乌克兰。没错。或者如果你身处俄罗斯，或者确切地说，身处 20 世纪 90 年代的南斯拉夫。我的意思是，我认为有大量的内战，或者说种族冲突，
where a sense of history is absolutely central to the stoking up of resentments, the sense of victimhood, the sense of fear that leads to hatred, that leads to violence. And if you take the history out, in other words, if people are no longer saying, well, let me tell you, great uncle so-and-so was butchered by the people next door and we'll never forget it. If you take that out, I mean, Northern Ireland might be a good example. The Serbs with the field of blackbirds, right?
在这些冲突中，历史意识绝对是煽动怨恨、受害者情结、恐惧感（进而导致仇恨，进而导致暴力）的核心。如果你抹去了历史，换句话说，如果人们不再说：“好吧，我告诉你，某某曾祖父被隔壁邻居屠杀过，我们永远不会忘记。”如果你抹去了这一点，北爱尔兰可能就是一个很好的例子。塞尔维亚人谈论黑鸟原野，对吧？
The Battle of Kosovo. Yeah, exactly. I mean, Vladimir Putin is a man who spent last summer writing a ridiculously long manifesto. Getting someone to write it for him. Right, exactly. Fair enough, Tom. But you know what I mean? I mean, I don't doubt that Putin has a sense of history, of Russia's history, and it's a sense of grievance based on history and if you took that out of course it's an implausible scenario because you never can take it out well but it reminds me of what you're saying is wouldn't we all be happier if we didn't have any memories right if we if all of a sudden we didn't remember any of the bad things that ever happened to us we would go through it's you know the planet of the apes comes to mind with the lobotomy you know or brave new world really
科索沃战役。对，没错。我的意思是，弗拉基米尔·普京就是一个去年夏天花时间写了一份荒谬的长篇宣言的人。找人替他代笔。对，没错。好吧，汤姆。但你知道我的意思吗？我的意思是，我不怀疑普京有历史感，对俄罗斯历史的历史感，这是一种基于历史的满腹怨气，如果你把这个抽离掉——当然，这是一个不切实际的假设，因为你永远无法把它抽离掉。好吧，但这让我想起了你的说法：如果我们没有任何记忆，难道我们不会都更快乐吗？对，如果突然之间我们不再记得发生在我们身上的任何坏事，我们将经历——你知道，人猿星球里的切除脑白质手术让人浮想联翩，或者说真的《美丽新世界》
i mean it's brave new world isn't? We're all just happy on drugs. But I mean, in the United States, we're talking about this cold civil war. History does seem to be at the heart of what people are tearing themselves to pieces over in the US at the moment. See, what that implies is that if we didn't have the history that we would be all, you know, lovey dovey instead. And I and there's two kinds of history. Maybe we could differentiate here if I'm going remember the last 10 years, that might be enough to cause 90% of the problems we have today. The United States does not have a long historical memory anyway, is the traditional knock on it compared to the old world, as we call it. So I don't know. I think that implies you need a reason to hate someone, and I'm not sure you do, although I was doing stories. I was a local news reporter when Yugoslavia broke up and we used to do things called localizing
我的意思是，这就是《美丽新世界》，对吧？我们所有人只是靠药物获得快乐。但我的意思是，在美国，我们在谈论这场冷战式的内战。在美国，历史似乎正处于人们目前争得不可开交的核心。你看，这暗示的意思是，如果我们没有历史，我们所有人都会变得，你知道的，充满爱意。而我有——历史有两种。也许我们可以区分一下，如果我只记得过去 10 年，这可能就足以引发我们今天遇到的 90% 的问题。相比于我们所谓的旧世界，美国本来就没有很长的历史记忆，这是对它的传统批评。所以，我不确定。这暗示你需要一个恨一个人的理由，而我不确定你是否真的需要，尽管我以前写过报道。当南斯拉夫解体时，我是一名地方新闻记者，我们过去常常做一些叫做“本地化新闻”的事情
the news which is you know you'll go find some people who live in your area who are expats or something from that area and while the big national network news is running actual footage of Sarajevo under siege you're talking to people who used to live there and asking them questions and they brought up just what you were mentioning, that these ethnic hatreds that have been such a long-term facet of the region. And as you all remember better than most, before the First World War, you had these terrible Balkan wars that had gone on. They had said that most of that had gone away.
也就是，你知道的，你会去找一些住在你们地区的、来自那个地区的侨民或类似的人，当全国电视网的新闻正在播放萨拉热窝被围困的真实画面时，你却在采访那些曾经住在那里的人，问他们问题，而他们说出了你刚才提到的话：这些种族仇恨一直是该地区长期存在的特征。正如你们比大多数人更清楚的那样，在第一次世界大战之前，曾经发生过这些可怕的巴尔干战争。他们曾说过，大部分那种仇恨已经消失了。
So imagine a fire that had died down to just the glowing coals. And then they had said that the the bad economic times that struck was seized upon by demagogues who were able to of how much they hated each other as a way to personally benefit or to create the conditions where greater Serbia could emerge or what have you. So in that sense, maybe you have a point. It would have been better to not have that memory to stoke again. Yeah. I once read a brilliant book, actually. What put this in my mind was I read a book by a guy called, I don't know if you heard this, Tom, by a guy called Jeremy Treglaun, and it's called Franco's Crypt. And it's about the Spanish Civil War. And most of the books that are written in English about the Spanish Civil War, sort of commentaries on it, talk about the unfinished business.
所以想象一下，一场已经熄灭到只剩下微弱红炭火的火灾。然后他们说，席卷而来的恶劣经济时期被蛊惑人心的政客利用了，这些政客能够利用彼此仇恨的程度，作为谋取个人私利或者创造大塞尔维亚崛起等条件的手段。所以从这个意义上说，你也许有道理。如果没有这段记忆可以再次煽动，情况可能会更好。是的。其实我曾经读过一本精彩的书。勾起我这个想法的是，我读了一本由一个人写的书——我不知道你有没有听过这个，汤姆——一个叫杰里米·特雷格伦（Jeremy Treglaun）的人写的，书名叫《弗兰克的地下室》（Franco's Crypt）。这本书讲的是西班牙内战。大多数用英文写的关于西班牙内战的书，也就是对其的一些评论，都在谈论未了的事情。
About this sort of, this sense that there was a culture of forgetting. And there are still graves where, you know, people are very keen to to sort of dig up to find the mass graves and so on and to sort of and and spanish politics still involves an enormous amount of arguing about the spanish civil war and in this book he said i think they should just let it go yeah i think i think it creates too much bad blood it intensifies political conflict and partisanship it creates a sense of us and them. And actually, sometimes there really is an argument, unjust as it may seem. And I do think it just seems unjust. But there may be an argument to just say, absolutely forget about it. Let it go.
谈论这种遗忘文化的意识。而且仍然有一些坟墓，你知道的，人们非常热衷于去挖掘，去寻找万人坑等等，并且——而且西班牙政治仍然包含着大量关于西班牙内战的争论。在这本书里，他说，我觉得他们应该就此放手。是的，我觉得这会激化太多不良情绪，加剧政治冲突和党派之争，并制造出“我们”与“他们”的对立感。实际上，有时候确实存在一种争论，尽管它看起来可能很不公正。而且我确实觉得它看起来很不公正。但或许有一个理由可以直接说：彻底忘掉它吧。让它过去吧。
Well, that was, I mean, it wasn't quite what Mandela said. He said, you know, forgiveness can become a kind of amnesia. Yeah. Up to a point but but look at how look at how weird this can get if we take it to the you know the the really uh the really big versions right it would be like saying if we could just forget the holocaust it would be you know it be such a weight off society's shoulders or blah, blah, blah. I mean, but that almost sounds offensive, but it's a unique situation. But it's not a unique situation, right? Because everybody, I mean, the field of blackbirds is its own kind of Holocaust, isn't it? Masada's still remembered.
好吧，这——我的意思，这不太符合曼德拉说过的话。他说过，你知道，遗忘可能会变成一种健忘症。是的。在某种程度上，但——但看看如果把它推向——你知道的，真正的大版本——事情会变得多么诡异，对吧？这就好比说，如果我们能忘掉大屠杀，那就（你知道的）会卸下社会肩头的一个重担，或者诸如此类的话。我的意思是，这听起来几乎带有冒犯性，但这是一个独特的情况。但这不是一个独特的情况，对吧？因为每个人——我的意思是，黑鸟原野有它自己的一种大屠杀，不是吗？马萨达至今仍被人们铭记。
The Armenians and the Turks are still remembered. I mean, at a certain point, to suggest that you just get over it is offensive to those people because you're asking them to forget their history. I mean, but listen, the point is well taken. The point is well taken. I mean, if you could just erase, if we could selectively erase people's memories so that the hatreds that are ancient were gone would be great, except that a lot of those hatreds exist for certain reasons. I mean, also there's a particular situation, say, in the United States or in Britain or in France, which are countries that traditionally have been very self-confident about their history. They have felt that British history or French history or American history is a cause of pride. It fosters a sense of patriotism. And a lot of the culture wars seem to me to be about whether that is
亚美尼亚人和土耳其人的事至今仍被铭记。我的意思是，在某种程度上，暗示你只要走出来就行了，这对那些人来说是具有冒犯性的，因为你是在要求他们忘记自己的历史。我的意思是，不过听着，这个观点很中肯。这个观点很中肯。我的意思是，如果你能直接抹去——如果我们能有选择地抹去人们的记忆，让那些古老的仇恨消失，那就太好了，只可惜很多仇恨的存在都是有一定原因的。我的意思是，这也存在一种特殊情况，比如在美国、英国或法国，这些国家传统上对自己的历史非常自信。他们觉得英国历史、法国历史或美国历史是骄傲的源泉。它培养了一种爱国主义意识。在我看来，许多文化战争似乎都围绕着这是否是事实展开，即在美国、英国或法国的历史中，是值得羞耻的部分多于值得骄傲的部分。而且我有一种感觉，那些通过反思自己国家的历史而感到快乐的人，当这种快乐感受到某种威胁时，往往是他们最愤怒的时候。你觉得呢？嗯，我觉得这是其中之一。而且这可能是我在提出时考虑得还不够周全的一点，因为我在想那些历史不那么值得称道的国家，对吧？换句话说，如果你今天是一个中国人，你会乐于回顾中国过去几百年的历史，还是会感到尴尬？对。但我想，考虑到中国文明的悠久历史，你会感到自豪的。
actually the case or not, whether there is more in American or British or French history to be ashamed of than to be proud of. And I get the sense that people who are made happy by reflecting on their country's history, that is one of the things that makes them most angry is when that sense of happiness is kind of threatened. Do you think? Well, I think it's one of those things. And it's a point I have not considered enough, perhaps, when you bring it up, because I'm thinking about the countries maybe that have histories that are a lot less laudable, right? In other words, would you be if you are a Chinese person today? Would you be happy recounting Chinese history in the last couple of hundred years or would you be embarrassed? Right. But you'd be proud, I think, thinking of the antiquity of Chinese civilization.
这是毫无疑问的。它在推动发展方面发挥了巨大作用。毫无疑问。但汤姆，我不认为你会感到羞耻或尴尬。我觉得你会——如果一个国家——我的感觉是，一个在过去，比如说，500年里可以说是逆来顺受的国家，他们讲述那个故事的方式——他们讲述故事的方式往往是我们在这些可怕的恶霸施加的巨大压力下展现出的韧性。我的意思是，这就是中国历史的故事，对吧？并不是说我们成了一个彻底的烂摊子，所有人都来入侵我们。更多的是我们随着时间的推移勇敢对抗了西方帝国主义。我们展现了韧性。
There's no question. And the great role that it's played in bringing. No question. But I don't think you'd be ashamed, Tom, or embarrassed. I think you would – if you're a country that has – my sense is that a country that has, as it were, been on the receiving end in the last, let's say, 500 years, the way you tell that – they tell that story tends to be our resilience under terrible pressure from these ghastly bullies. I mean, that's the story of Chinese history, right? It's not we were a complete basket case and everybody invaded us. It's more we stood up over time to Western imperialism. We were resilient.
所以中国绝对有自豪感。我想说，国家几乎总是试图在自己的历史中寻找自豪感。好吧，除了——我的意思是，我正在考虑美国的例子，传统上，独立战争和国父们的故事一直是骄傲的源泉。而美国的开端也与独立战争联系在一起。但最近，当然，它与 17 世纪初第一批奴隶被带到美洲联系在了一起。
So there is definitely pride in China. I would say countries almost always try to find pride in their history. Well, except that. I mean, I'm thinking the case of the United States, that traditionally the story of the revolution and the founding fathers has been a cause of pride. And the beginnings of America is identified with the Revolutionary War. But recently, of course, it's been identified with the bringing of the first slaves to America in the early 17th century.
这产生了一种反叙事，本质上要求美国人停止为自己的历史感到那么高兴；英国也是如此，对大多数英国人来说，丘吉尔是个英雄，他拯救了英国，拯救了世界，但现在出现了一种反叙事，强调，你知道的，他是个种族主义者，他做了这个，他做了那个。汤姆，我的意思是，也许丹——丹可以纠正我如果我错了，但我会说你所谈论的那些争论，是小群体内部的争论——那些高度受教育的、主要以大学和媒体为基础的少数群体。我不确定这些争论在多大程度上渗透到了普通公众当中。但我认为这就是——我的意思是，我记得有些——我不记得是在哪里了。如果有人说，“觉醒废话”是——
And that has generated a kind of counter narrative which asks americans essentially to stop being quite so happy about their history and the same here in britain where most britains were churchill is a hero he saved britain he saved the world but now there's a kind of counter narrative that emphasizes you know he was a racist he did this he did that tom i mean maybe dan dan can um correct me if i'm wrong but i would say those arguments that you're talking about are arguments within small, highly educated, largely university and media based minorities. And I'm not sure how much they percolated to the general public. But I think that that's what, I mean, I remember some, I can't remember where it was. If somebody said, woke Tosh is.
这是我吗？我说过这个吗？没有，不是你。“觉醒废话”是人们在学校里被灌输的关于历史的东西，而这些东西你在学校里并没有学到，那种感觉是，大学里的学者们正在对乔治·华盛顿或温斯顿·丘吉尔挑毛病，他们怎么敢这么做。你怎么看，丹？我觉得这就是——你知道的，我一直在谈论这个，你们俩绝对完全清楚——历史人物在几个世纪或几十年后在我们眼中的形象，与他们在当时眼中的形象之间的区别，他们是如何被压扁成一个二维人物的，这个二维人物更像是某种事物的象征，对吧？你为之树立雕像的人，是因为他们在当时发挥了某种作用。你知道的，在当时的社会里，你立了雕像，对吧，作为榜样或是
Is this me? Did I say this say this no it wasn't you woke tosh is the stuff that people get taught about history in schools that you weren't taught in your school that sense that people academics in in universities are chipping away at george washington or winston churchill and how dare they What do you think, Dan? I think that it's the difference between, you know, I talk about it all the time and you guys know this absolutely perfectly. It's the difference between how a historical figure looks to us centuries or decades later versus what they looked like at the time, how they get squashed into a two-dimensional figure that's more of a representation of something, right? Someone you put a statue up because they serve a purpose. You know, in your society at the time, you put the statue up, right, as an example or
可以仰望或效仿的对象。然而，当你给那个二维人物加水，让他们重新变得三维，并且你看到他们身上的所有缺点时，我觉得这里有两个因素在起作用。第一，一种几乎被背叛的感觉，对吧？我们的英雄怎么可能是个种族主义者呢？但同时，这也有一种感觉，即历史不止一面。所以，比方说，如果要我上一门关于温斯顿·丘吉尔的课，我希望每个周一、周三、周五，都能请来一个极度崇拜丘吉尔的人，而在周二、周四，你能请来一个——而在周二、周四，你能请来一个指出他所有缺点的人，从而使这个人变得三维立体。而且你——我认为当你这样做的时候，你开始打破人们的一种观念，即如果一个人有缺点，人们就不应该再崇拜他了。就像我前几天和某人聊天时提到的，因为托马斯·杰斐逊出现在我最近的节目中，我试图指出，如果托马斯·杰斐逊因为拥有奴隶而是一个糟糕的人，但他推动自由和解放思想的事实，实际上帮助了世界各地抓住这些思想并以此作为自身正当性依据的奴隶制社会。而我当时说的是——我并不是说他是那样的人，我不是想表达这个——但让我们想象一下，一个发明了在世界历史上拯救了数百万生命的伟大疫苗的人，其实是个糟糕的人。好吧，人们依然会庆祝这一成就。人们不必去爱这个人。所以我觉得我们对这些历史人物感到如此愤怒的很大一部分原因，在于有一种感觉，要么是他们让我们失望了，对吧？或者这种感觉——要么是他们让我们失望了，对吧？或者这种
something to look forward to or to emulate. Whereas when you add water to that two-dimensional figure and they three-dimensionalize again and you see them with all their warts, I think there's two things in play. One, a sense of almost betrayal, right? How can our hero be a racist, for example? But also this sort of a feel that there's more than one side to history. So, for example, if I was going to teach a course on Winston Churchill, I would love to have every, you know, Monday, Wednesday, Friday, you bring in somebody who's an enormous fan of Churchill, and Tuesday, Thursday, you bring in somebody who's an enormous fan of Churchill and Tuesday, Thursday, you bring in somebody who brings up all the bad points and you three dimensionalize the person. And you and and that I think when you do that, you begin to to to disabuse people of the notion that if somebody has warts, one should not revere them anymore. It's like I was talking to somebody the other day because Thomas Jefferson came up in the recent show that I had, and I was trying to point out that if Thomas Jefferson was
感觉是我们正在庆祝一个并非如此优秀的人。但你确实可以从中挖掘出好的一面。这就像一个钟摆，不是吗？钟摆在找到新的基准线之前，往往会过度矫正。看，我们难道不应该明白丘吉尔的观点在今天会被认为是种族主义吗？我们绝对应该明白。但丘吉尔的观点在今天会被认为是种族主义，这一点我们绝对应该承认，不过这应该在一个背景下呈现：如果生活在 19 世纪 80 年代、90 年代的人中，我们唯一能颂扬的人必须是不符合现代标准的种族主义者——那些在那个地方、那个时代长大的人——那将是一个非常小的群体，而且除了这一点之外，我们可能没有其他理由去赞美他们。但同时，我想，难道不是吗——我的意思是我同意你所说的一切，
a horrible person for owning slaves, the fact that he pushed forward these ideas of freedom and liberty actually helps slave societies all over the world who seized upon those ideas and used them for their own justification. And what I had said was, and I don't mean that he was, I'm not trying to say that, but let's imagine a guy who invents one of the great vaccines that has saved millions of lives in world history was a terrible person. Well, one still celebrates the achievement. One doesn't have to love the person. And so I feel like a lot of the reason we get so angry, these historical figures, is there's this sense that they have either let us down, right? Or this sense that we're either let us down, right, or this
丹，但我会认为，作为一个社会，也许我们对缺点的容忍度比 50 年或 100 年前要低。换句话说，我不认为——也许我们对“缺点”的定义已经变了。就是这样。我正要这么说，汤姆，完全正确。但我认为从来没有一个时期，人们——如果你以丘吉尔为例，或者甚至是美国的国父们——我的意思是，即使在竖起雕像的时候，我认为也从来没有一个时期，人们真诚地认为这些人是纯洁无瑕、圣洁无比、绝对无可指责的人物。我的意思是，丘吉尔就是一个明显的例子。每个人都知道丘吉尔的各种缺点、犯下的错误、出格的公开言论，所有诸如此类的事情。但他们对什么是人性有着成熟的看法。换句话说，任何知名的公众人物，按定义都难免说过或做过一些人们可能会觉得反感的事情。我不知道现在的气候是否更不利于那种对人性的宽容看法，以及我们是否比我们的前辈对缺点更缺乏容忍度。好吧，不过你提到了一个关于丘吉尔的好观点，那就是，这是一个活得足够久的人，他出生在一个其观点并不具争议性的时期，并亲历了这些观点发生改变的时刻，对吧？所以这是一个活得足够久的人，他出生在一个其观点并不具争议性的时期，并亲历了这些观点发生改变的时刻。
sense that we're celebrating somebody who's not this good person. But there are definitely good things you can tease. It's a pendulum, isn't it, where the pendulum tends to overcorrect before it finds its new baseline, which, look, should we understand that Churchill had views that we were considered to be racist today? We absolutely should. But that Churchill had views that we were considered to be racist today we absolutely should but that should be presented in the context that if only people in the night who born in the 1880s 1890s if the only people we can celebrate are the ones who weren't racist by today's standards who grew up in that place in that time it's going to be a remarkably small group of people and they may have no other reason to laud them except for that. But also, I suppose, isn't there, I mean, I agree with everything
对吧。所以这是一个到他去世时，遭到英国统治阶级整个阶层痛骂的人。对吧。正如你所说，甚至在他鼎盛时期，其中一些人——我认为这和我 20 世纪 70 年代成长时期的经历有点不同，当时我们依然那样看待乔治·华盛顿。我不记得听到过关于这家伙的任何坏话，对吧——我的意思是，那时候就是在为你们的国父树立雕像，并在他们周围创造神话，对吧，我们当时还在谈论乔治·华盛顿不会说谎、砍掉樱桃树之类的东西，而这可是在 20 世纪 70 年代，所以我觉得这也许要具体人物具体分析吧。对，好吧，好吧。
you're saying, Dan, but I would argue that we're more, as a society, maybe we are less tolerant of warts than we might have been 50 or 100 years ago. In other words, I don't think- Perhaps our sense of what warts are has changed. That's it. I was just going to say that, Tom, exactly. But I don't think there was ever a time when people, if you take Churchill, let's say, or indeed the American founding fathers, I mean, even when the statues were put up, I don't think there was ever a time when people genuinely thought these are pristine, saintly, utterly unimpeachable figures. I mean, Churchill is the obvious example. Everybody knew about the various
——我觉得这也许要具体人物具体分析吧。对，好吧，好吧。我觉得是时候进入下一个极其重要的问题了。汤姆，在你这么做之前，让我们先休息一下。
flaws that the church had, the mistakes, the outrageous public statements, all those kinds of things. But they had a mature view of what it was to be human. In other words, that any well-known public figure was bound by definition to have said and done things that people might find objectionable. I wonder whether the current climate is more hostile to that sort of capacious view of human nature and that we are less tolerant of failings than our predecessors might have been. Well, but you bring up a good point about Churchill, which is here's a guy who lived long enough to be born in a period where his views were not controversial and lived through when those views had changed, right? So here's a guy who lived long enough to be born in a period where his views were not controversial and live through when those those views had changed.
我们一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的 restis》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将为你揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的机会，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
Right. So here's a man who, by the time he dies, is is reviled by a whole segment of the British governing class. Right. And as you said, even during his prime, some of them, I think that's a little bit different than the way when I'm growing up in the 1970s, we still view George Washington. And I don't remember hearing a bad thing about the guy ever right i mean it was it was the the put up statues to your founding fathers and and create a myth around them yeah we were still taking talking about george washington cannot tell a lie chopping down the cherry tree stuff and this is in the 1970s so i think it's on a figure by figure basis maybe yeah okay okay um i think it's on a figure by figure basis, maybe. Yeah. Okay. Okay. I think it's time to move on to another hugely important question. Tom, before you do that, let us take a quick break.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 restis》。汤姆，对不起，我知道我刚才粗暴地打断了你，是为了通过我们深受喜爱的广告插播环节来满足我们忠实的商业合作伙伴。所以听好了，让我们抛出第六个问题吧。请出题，汤姆。丹，你是公元 1000 年欧亚大陆某个国家的统治者，所以是在欧亚大陆的任何地方，你会选择拥有以下哪项发明？你只能选一个：火药、印刷术，或者疾病细菌说。哇。好吧，作为一个统治者，除了火药之外，其他这些听起来对我都不是很好，因为那是唯一一个我认为能为我所用的东西，对吧？因为如果我
We'll see you in a second. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&AA we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
不一定会在乎任何——我是说，你知道的，印刷术对我来说是一个迟早要发生负面效应的东西。作为一个统治者，你简直疯了。对，你绝不希望有任何关于这个的东西。别去翻译那些我普通百姓能读懂的文本。这太容易选了。至于火药这东西，正如你们大家所知，火药在任何人找到在战争中有效使用它的方法之前，就已经存在很长时间了。所以我不确定作为一个公元 1000 年的欧亚大陆统治者，我除了用这东西搞点五颜六色的烟花之外，还能琢磨出什么别的用处。所以我默认选择历史的细菌说，因为其他两样东西对我来说听起来都不像我作为一个统治者会想要的东西。也许，哪怕仅仅是因为历史的细菌说有助于保护我和我的人民，并且也许能给我一些线索，让我知道如何把它武器化来对付我的敌人。说不定你会被人们记住是“好人丹”。如果我有话语权的话
That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello and welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom, I'm sorry, I know I rudely interrupted you there to ensure that we satisfy our loyal commercial partners with one of our greatly loved ad breaks. So listen, let's fire away with question number six. Off you go, Tom. Dan, you are the ruler of a Eurasian state in AD 1000, so anywhere in Eurasia, which one of the following inventions would you choose to have? And you can only have one, gunpowder, the printing press, or the germ theory of disease. Wow. Well, as a ruler, none of those sound that good to me other than gunpowder, because that's the only one I think I can use for me, right? Because if I'm
用我的印刷术，我就会这样去铭记它。细菌说。我是说，我在考虑公元 1000 年的统治者，比如克努特大帝。对。或者“无准备者”埃塞尔雷德。对，他们会——他们会用细菌说来做什么？去感染麦西亚人吗？你知道的，其实，建立医院和照顾病人是非常重要的，我可看不出克努特会做那种事，汤姆。哦，当然，他做了。真的吗？他去罗马朝圣了，那是为了他自己的目的。那让他看起来很体面。那绝对是一个展现权力的举动。对，没错。那跟对患天花的人好不好可没半毛钱关系。我觉得你未免太愤世嫉俗了。
not necessarily going to care about any, I mean, you know, the printing press, to me, that's a negative waiting to happen. As a ruler, you're demented. Yeah, you don't want anything about that. Don't be translating texts that my average people can read. That's an easy one. And the gunpowder thing, I mean, as you guys all know, I mean, gunpowder was in existence for a long time before anybody found a way to usefully use it in warfare. So I'm not sure that as the Eurasian ruler in 1000 that I'm going to manage to figure out anything other than some colorful fireworks for a while with that stuff. So I'm going to default to the germ theory of history because the other two to me don't sound like what I as a ruler would want. And maybe if only because a germ theory of history helps me protect me and mine and maybe gives me some clues as to how maybe I could weaponize it against my enemies. And you might be remembered as Dan the Good. If I had anything to say about
不过，说真的，多米尼克，你会选什么？好吧，我完全同意。当你宣读这个问题时，我最初想到的是印刷术，但当然，当你宣读这个问题时，我想到了“欧亚大陆一个国家的统治者”。所以，好吧，所以，如果你是一个欧亚大陆国家的统治者——所以好吧，如果你是一个欧亚大陆国家的统治者，而且你只有一辈子的时间，那么如果你选择印刷术，你就是疯了。如果你是在玩一个控制一个国家一千年左右的电脑游戏，那你当然会选择印刷术，对吧？对。但是——但是，不，我可能会选择——我只是不明白他们会怎么用细菌说或火药，这才是问题所在。
it with my printing press, that is how I would remember it. The germ theory. I mean, I'm thinking about rulers in the year 1000, so Canute. Yes. Or Ethelred the Unready.ready yeah what are they gonna what are they gonna do with the germ theory infect the infect the merseians you know well well um actually the setting up of hospitals is a caring for the sick is very important i don't see canute doing that tom yeah of course he did did he he went on pilgrimage to rome that was for his own purposes that That made him look good. That's a power move right there. Right, exactly. That's nothing to do with being kind to people who've got smallpox. I think you're being unduly cynical.
好吧，烟花。我挺喜欢烟花的想法的。好吧，好吧。你是个中国皇帝。对。但他们用它来干嘛了？
But, I mean, Dominic, what would you choose? Well, I completely agree. When you read out the question, I initially thought the printing press, but of course when you read out the question, and I thought ruler of a Eurasian state. So, okay, so yeah, if you're a ruler of a Eurasian state um so it's okay so yeah this is if you're a ruler of a eurasian state and you've only got one lifetime as it were you're mad to choose the printing press if you're playing a computer game in which you're controlling a state for a thousand
但想象一下，如果你是巴格达的哈里发，你拥有印刷术。但你会控制它吗？印刷术的本质是……历史上有没有哪个国家的政权得到了印刷术，然后……然后一切没有变得一团糟？对，然后这个政权拥有了垄断权并一直保持了下来。这是一个具有破坏性的
years or something obviously you do choose the printing press right right but but no i choose probably i just don't see what they're gonna do with the germ theory or gunpowder though that's the problem. Well, the fireworks. I like the thought of the fireworks. Okay, okay. You're a Chinese emperor. Yeah. But what did they do with it?
力量，不是吗，印刷术？好吧，但我认为这在很大程度上揭示了你统治欧亚大陆国家的方法论。因为你可能会说，作为一个统治者，你关心的是你的人民的繁荣、健康和幸福。只要把我也包括在内就行。而且可能会出现分歧。
But imagine you're a caliph in Baghdad and you have a printing press. But would you control it, though? The nature of a printing press is… Is there ever an instance in history of a state that got the printing press and then the regime... And then it didn't go horribly wrong. Yeah, and then the regime had a monopoly which it kept. It's a destabilising
好吧，汤姆，我来跟你讲讲我的历史理论。所以我儿子在学校里前几天被问到一个问题——因为大家都知道他爸爸和伟大的汤姆·霍兰一起做历史播客。他们问：“他有没有跟你讲过任何关于伟大的汤姆·霍兰的事情？”他们问：“他有没有跟你讲过任何关于历史教训的事情？”他当着全班的面说：“是的，你的邻居可能会试图杀死并吃掉你。所以你应该先吃掉他们。”太对了。这就是历史的教训。这里面甚至可以印一件 T 恤。你看，我会选择印刷术，因为我想把教育带给我的人民，让他们更快乐、更明智。我不信。他们会推翻你的。在某个地方。你看，我会选择印刷术，因为我想把教育带给我的人民。
force, isn't it, the printing press? Okay, but I think this is revealing quite a lot about the approach that you would bring to ruling a Eurasian state. Because you might say that as a ruler, your concern is with the prosperity and health and happiness of your people. As long as mine's included in that. And there may be a divergence.
我不信。并让他们更快乐、更明智。我不信。他们会推翻你的。好吧，也许吧。但我死的时候会知道我做了一件好事。好吧。所以我想我们都同意了。汤姆是错的。
Well, I'll tell you, Tom, about my theory of history. So my son at school was asked the other day, because everybody knows that his dad does history podcasts with the great Tom Holland. And they said, does he ever tell you anything about the great Tom Holland. And they said, does he ever tell you anything about the lessons from history? And he said in front of the whole class, he said, yes, your neighbors will probably try to kill and eat you. So you should eat them first. So true. That is the lesson of history. There's a t-shirt in there somewhere. You see, I would go for the printing press because I would want to bring education to my people and make them happier and wiser. I don't believe you. They would overthrow you. Somewhere. You see, I would go for the printing press because I would want to bring education to my people.
睿智的汤姆。汤姆，你的思维方式不像一个公元 1000 年的统治者。我的意思是，那些人——我是说，统治者，对吧？不是普通公民，不是神职人员。阿尔弗雷德大帝。阿尔弗雷德大帝。伟大的识字率倡导者。好吧。他会拥有印刷术的。我同意你的看法。是的，绝对会。他是个伟大的国王。所以这就是我的选择。那么，让我们再次回到 20 世纪。所以，丹，你认为西方会输掉冷战吗？
I don't believe you. And make them happier and wiser. I don't believe you. They would overthrow you. Well, that's as may be. But I would die knowing that I'd done good. All right. So I think we're all agreed. Tom is wrong.
是的，我认为他们可能会输掉冷战。我能问一下，输掉冷战意味着什么吗？好吧，这很有趣，不是吗？那会是什么样子？挨核打击吗？不，不，这是一个很好的问题。我认为，输掉冷战正如我们当时所定义的——我们所有人都足够老，还记得那场游戏是怎么玩的，对吧——对于世界的很多地方来说，就是变成共产主义国家，对吧？那是当时的方式，我是说，伴随着多米诺骨牌理论，我的意思是，这就是你当时衡量自己是在赢得还是在
Tom the wise. Tom, you're not thinking like a ruler from the one. I mean, those people, I mean, ruler, right? Not average citizen, not cleric. Alfred the Great. Alfred the Great. Great sponsor of literacy. Okay. He would have had a printing press. I agree with you. Yeah, absolutely. And he's a great king. So that's who I'm going with. So let's get back to 20th century again. So Dan, do you think the West could have lost the Cold War?
输掉冷战的标准。这也是为什么那么多代理人战争会被打响，或者说这至少是当时公开的借口，对吧？所以，假如多米诺骨牌理论真的存在，虽然我个人认为并不存在，但让我们假设它曾经存在过。也许是为了呼应多米尼克所说的话，赢得战争可能意味着——我的意思是，失败就意味着没有获胜。对。我的意思是，简单来说，就是没有让苏联解体。单单这一点或许就已经足够构成胜利了，这取决于你如何看待它。但我确实认为，如果你说西方不可能赢得、不可能输掉冷战，那是在暗示西方任何主要领导人所犯下的任何错误，其后果都不足以让他们输掉这场游戏。换句话说，你是说每一位美国总统基本上都可以开启自动驾驶模式，或者做出糟糕的决策，但最终结果依然是我们会赢得冷战，而我根本不相信这一点。我的意思是，有两种可能，对吧？呃，所以可能会发生一场没有人能赢的核战争，所以我想——
Yes, I think they could have lost the Cold War. Could I just ask, what does losing the Cold War mean? Well, that's the interesting thing, isn't it? What would that look like? Getting nuked? No, no, that's a very good question. I think that losing the Cold War as we had defined it, and all of us are old enough to remember how that game was played, right, would have been for lots of the world to have gone communist, right? That was the way, I mean, with the domino theory, I mean, this was how you measured how you were either winning or
是的，我认为他们本可能会输掉冷战。我能问一下，输掉冷战意味着什么吗？嗯，这正是最有趣的地方，不是吗？那会是什么样子？挨原子弹？不，不，这是一个非常好的问题。我认为，按照我们当时对冷战的定义——我们所有人的年龄都足够大，还记得那场游戏是怎么玩的——输掉冷战就意味着世界上很多地方都赤化了，对吧？这就是当时的现状，我是说，伴随着多米诺骨牌理论，这就是你衡量自己当时是赢还是
losing at that time. And that's why so many of these proxy wars were fought, or certainly what the excuse was openly, right? So had there been a reality to the domino theory, which I don't think there was in my own opinion, but let's imagine that there had been. And maybe to piggyback off of what Dominic was saying is that maybe winning simply me. I mean, losing means not winning. Right. I mean, simply not having the Soviet Union fall. That may be victory enough, depending on how you're viewing it. But I do think to say that the West couldn't have won, couldn't have lost the Cold War is to insinuate that no mistake made by any major leader in the West would have been consequential enough to have cost them the game. In other words, you're saying that every American president essentially could have just been on autopilot or make terrible decisions and yet the end result would be we'd win the cold war anyway and i just don't buy that i mean there are two ways aren't there really uh so there's a nuclear war in which nobody wins so that i guess
输的标准。这就是为什么会爆发那么多代理人战争，或者至少当时的公开借口是这样的，对吧？所以，如果多米诺骨牌理论成为现实（虽然在我看来并没有，但我们假设它曾经存在过），也许正如多米诺所说的那样，赢本身就意味着……我的意思是，输就是没有赢。对吧？我的意思是，仅仅是苏联没有解体。这或许就已经是胜利了，这取决于你是如何看待它的。但我确实认为，如果说西方不可能赢得、不可能输掉冷战，就是在暗示西方任何主要领导人犯下的任何错误都不会严重到让他们输掉这场游戏。换句话说，你的意思是，基本上每一位美国总统都可以处于自动驾驶状态或者做出糟糕的决定，然而最终的结果是我们无论如何都会赢得冷战，我根本不买账。我的意思是，实际上有两种可能，对吧？呃，一种是无人获胜的核战争，所以我想
is always was always a risk but isn't the stake in the cold war basically who controls europe yeah it's only the beginning at the beginning it basically who controls Europe? Yeah, it's only the beginning. In the beginning, it's who controls Europe. Well, you guys, wait a minute. Are we thinking about this in traditional geopolitical terms or are we thinking about this in the ideological terms that colored that war? Because if you're thinking about this as though it were Alfred the Great's England and that's how we're grading things, well, then it's a different story. But I think the people at the time would have seen the ideological winning and losing to be the main issue, not the geopolitical. You know, how far has the Soviet Union expanded westward? You know, I mean, I mean, in that sense, then communism doesn't matter. and Dyer's attitude that if you took the ideology out of it, that the Cold War would have been
一直都是，一直都是一种风险，但冷战的核心不就是谁来控制欧洲吗？是的，这只是开始，在最初，基本上就是谁来控制欧洲？是的，这只是开始。在最初，是关于谁来控制欧洲。好吧，伙们，等一下。我们在用传统的冷战地缘政治术语来思考这个问题，还是在用给那场战争涂上色彩的意识形态术语来思考？因为如果你把这当成阿尔弗雷德大帝的英格兰来评分，那又是另一回事了。但我认为当时的人们会把意识形态上的胜负视为主要问题，而不是地缘政治。你知道，苏联向西扩张了多远？你知道，我的意思是，从那个意义上讲，共产主义就无足轻重了。而戴尔的观点是，如果你抽离意识形态，冷战对16世纪的西班牙外交官等人来说，完全可以被理解为一场纯粹的权力游戏。
completely understandable to, you know, 16th century Spanish diplomats and whatever as a pure power game. But I think if you're the United States and you're talking about the kind of arguments we used to have amongst Republicans and Democrats and hawks and doves, it all would have been ideological based rather than some geopolitical question. On the ideological front, Soviet communism collapsed, but the world's most dynamic state at the moment is at least nominally a communist country with the party in control. Well, what if India had gone communist? I mean, what if, what if, what if, I mean, so you're talking about the Chinese version of this. Well, what if somehow India had gone communist too? And you had an India Chinese, I mean, fascinating things to think about.
但我想，如果你是美国，而你讨论的是我们过去在共和党人与民主党人、鹰派与鸽派之间进行的那些争论，这一切都将是基于意识形态的，而不是某种地缘政治问题。在意识形态阵营方面，苏联共产主义崩溃了，但目前世界上最具活力的国家至少名义上是一个由党控制的共产主义国家。好吧，如果印度变成了共产主义呢？我的意思是，如果，如果，如果……我的意思是，所以你谈论的是中国的这个版本。好吧，如果印度不知何故也变成了共产主义呢？然后你有了印度和中国——我的意思是，这是令人着迷的想法。
Yeah. I mean, I things to think about. Yeah. I mean, I think the West could have lost the Cold War. You see, growing up in Britain in the 1980s, my understanding of the Cold War, who was going to win or lose, was would Britain end up communist? Yeah. Maybe that's a very… Or kind of within the Soviet sphere.
是啊。我是说……有些事情要去思考。是的。我的意思是，我认为西方本可能会输掉冷战。你看，在20世纪80年代的英国长大，我对冷战以及谁会输赢的理解是：英国最终会变成共产主义吗？是的。也许这是一个非常……或者说处于苏联的势力范围之内。
I mean, as Dan says, there are two different ways of looking at it, aren't there? There's the way where you look at the maps that we grew up with in Britain, which were the division in Europe. Yes, and with kind of Warsaw Pact units and NATO units and blocks and things. Is it plausible? I think I was over-influenced by General Sir John Hackett's The Third World War. Did you ever read that? I read a lot of Hackett stuff i didn't read that one well it kind of he it was actually quite rather chilling because it was um it was i think it
我的意思是，正如丹所说，有两种不同的看待方式，不是吗？有一种方式是看我们在英国一起长大的那些地图，也就是欧洲的分裂。是的，还有华约部队和北约部队以及各种阵营等等。这合理吗？我想我当时深受约翰·哈克特爵士的《第三次世界大战》的影响。你读过那本书吗？我读过很多哈克特的作品，但没读过那本。嗯，它有点……其实相当令人不寒而栗，因为它……它是……我想它
was set i think he wrote it 1978 so it was before iran went toto and it kind of it tried to work out how a war soul pact nato war in europe would pan out and the war soul pact starts to lose rather in the way that Putin perhaps is suffering reverses in Ukraine at the moment. And the Soviets choose to escalate it by nuking Birmingham in England. They do nuking Birmingham, don't they? And so NATO then have to respond and they nuke Minsk. And it's on a kind of knife edge whether the whole world is now going to get nuked.
背景设定在——我想他是1978年写的，所以是在伊朗发生大动荡之前——它试图推演欧洲的华约与北约战争会如何发展，而华约开始战败，就像普京目前在乌克兰遭受挫折一样。苏联人选择通过向英国伯明翰投掷核弹来升级战争。他们真的轰炸了伯明翰，对吧？所以北约随后不得不做出回应，他们轰炸了明斯克。现在整个世界是否会被核打击正处于千钧一发的边缘。
And there is a coup in Moscow. And Hackett said this was the only way he could think of to stop nuclear armageddon happening which is a cheery a cheery thing to bear in mind perhaps at the moment i mean the question i suppose the the the question that underpins this is um was communism doomed to fail and um i'm not convinced necessarily that it was i mean we did a series of podcasts about the Soviet Union in the 1980s and then Russia in the 1990s. And the sort of the contingency, the great contingency is the arrival of Gorbachev. If you take Gorbachev out of the equation,
莫斯科发生了政变。哈克特说，这是他能想到的唯一能阻止核末日发生的方法——这或许是目前值得铭记的一件令人振奋的事情。我的意思是，这个问题，我猜……支撑这个的核心问题是：共产主义注定要失败吗？嗯，我不一定确信它是注定失败的。我的意思是，我们做了一系列关于20世纪80年代苏联以及随后20世纪90年代俄罗斯的播客。那种偶然性，最大的偶然性就是戈尔巴乔夫的到来。如果你把戈尔巴乔夫从这个方程式中拿掉，
it's not obvious to me that the USSR dissolves in 1991. Communism, what one party state I would say could have, well, I i mean there's no reason why it couldn't have continued indefinitely if it's done so in china with there's a wonderful theory though i mean and let me throw this out there because i i remember hearing it from a military guy first and i've since seen it in print in a number of different places and it has to do you know um in the in the united states we have a um uh uh what's the word here we have a what's the word here? We have a sort of a totem, for lack of that's taken control about how and why the Soviet Union fell. And it's the whole Reagan outspent them kind of thing. But that's the military guy that I spoke to. And like I said, I've since seen this in multiple places, had a much better point, which is that if you look at where military hardware development was going, and starting in the late 1970s,
在我看来，苏联在1991年解体并不是显而易见的。共产主义，一个一党制的国家，我认为……我的意思是，没有理由说它不能无限期地持续下去，既然它在中国已经做到了这一点。不过，有一个绝妙的理论——我的意思是，让我把它抛出来，因为我记得最初是从一个军方人士那里听说的，后来我在许多不同的地方的印刷品中都见过它——它与……你知道的……在美国，我们有一个……呃……呃……这里的词是什么？我们有一个……这里的词是什么？我们有一个某种图腾，由于缺乏更好的词，它主导了关于苏联如何以及为什么倒台的看法。这就是里根把他们拖垮的那种说法。但这就是我交谈过的那位军方人士……就像我说的，我后来在多个地方看到了这个观点，它有一个好得多观点，那就是如果你看看军事硬件发展当时的走向，从20世纪70年代末开始，
the systems were going to require heavier-duty computer elements to it that eventually was going to require the equivalence of communication and all sorts of things that were the antithesis of what the Soviet society could have handled. In other words, if you want the brand-new, really good tanks and aircraft, you're going to have to allow your society to develop technologically to levels that can compete with the West. But you can't do that in a closed society. And the argument was that part of what Gorbachev was doing with this glasnost was not some peace and love, wonderful thing.
这些系统将需要更高端的计算机元件，最终将需要相当于通信和各种各样的东西，而这些正是苏联社会所无法应付的对立面。换句话说，如果你想要崭新的、真正出色的坦克和飞机，你就必须允许你的社会在技术上发展到能够与西方竞争的水平。但在一个封闭的社会里，你是做不到这一点的。我的论点是，戈尔巴乔夫通过“公开性”所做的事情，部分并不是什么爱好和平、美妙的事情。
It was an attempt to open up the door enough so that you could continue to compete militarily with the West that was going to defeat you eventually with drones and satellites and all these things. I mean, can you imagine the Soviet Union, who was afraid and upset with one radio signal crossing the Iron Curtain with Radio Free Europe? Can you imagine them trying to deal with it with Twitter? I mean, the two things almost can't coexist. And you'd have to be like North Korea. And if you're like North Korea, can you really have the top sort of weaponry and communication technologies you need to compete with the West without the openness that those tools sort of commit you to? Does that make sense? But it's interesting, isn't it? Because
这是一种尝试，旨在把门打开得足够大，以便能够继续在军事上与西方竞争——西方最终会用无人机、卫星和所有这些东西击败你。我的意思是，你能想象苏联吗？它曾对一个越过铁幕的广播信号（自由欧洲电台）感到恐惧和不安。你能想象他们试图用推特来应对吗？我的意思是，这两者几乎是无法共存的。你必须像朝鲜一样。如果你像朝鲜那样，在没有那些工具必然会带给你的开放性的情况下，你真的能拥有与西方竞争所需的顶级武器和通信技术吗？这说得通吗？但这就很有趣了，不是吗？因为
China undoubtedly has kind of picked up on the lesson that to compete with the West, you need to be absolutely the cutting edge of tech and seems to have done it very successfully, but has not gone for the kind of open society option. Oh, but they're much more open than the old. I mean, imagine the Soviet Union in the 50s looks much more like North Korea does in China. I mean, there are people who say China's got a got a sort of a communist patina on it now, but that it's not really what we would. I mean, what can you imagine what somebody like Stalin or Gorbachev or someone like Khrushchev would have said about modern-day China and how well that fit into the Trotsky-Leninist-Bakaran paradigm? I mean, it doesn't even look like a communist country of the sort we grew up.
中国毫无疑问已经吸取了这样一个教训：要与西方竞争，你需要站在科技的最前沿，并且似乎非常成功地做到了这一点，但它并没有选择开放社会的道路。哦，但它们比过去开放得多。我的意思是，想象一下50年代的苏联，它看起来比中国更像今天的朝鲜。我的意思是，有人说中国现在身上披着一层共产主义的外衣，但它并不是我们真正……我的意思是，你能想象斯大林、戈尔巴乔夫或赫鲁晓夫这样的人会对现代中国以及这如何很好地契合托洛茨基-列宁主义-布哈林主义范式说些什么吗？我的意思是，它看起来甚至不像我们成长时期那种共产主义国家。
It just looks like an authoritarian country. Yeah, that's a fair point. I think that is a fair point, that it's not in any meaningful way a kind of Marxist-Leninist country, is it? Or indeed a Maoist country. But it's quite a totalitarian becoming a more, I mean, under Xi, it is becoming... Yeah, it's an authoritarian
它看起来只像一个威权国家。是的，这倒是个中肯的观点。我认为这是一个中肯的观点，它在任何有意义的层面上都不是一个马克思列宁主义国家，对吧？或者说甚至不是一个毛主义国家。但它是一个相当极权主义的……变得更加……我的意思是，在习的领导下，它正在变成……是的，这是一个威权
society. Becoming more authoritarian. I mean, in 30 years' time, people may be asking the same question about the contest between the United States and China, perhaps. Who knows? I don't know. Yeah. Anyway. so what did we decide on this we decided the west well dan you said the west could have lost well but if you say they couldn't have lost then then then none of the decisions that were made matter yeah i suppose well for example i there's a scenario i suppose in which the united states walks away at the end of the 1940s or early 1950s in a similar way to what happened after the First World War.
社会。变得更加威权。我的意思是，30年后的今天，人们可能也会对美国和中国之间的竞争提出同样的问题，也许吧。谁知道呢？我不知道。是的。不管怎样。那么我们对此作何决定？我们决定西方——好吧，丹，你说过西方本可能会输。但如果你说他们不可能输，那么……那么……所有做出的决定就都无关紧要了。是的，我想……好吧，例如，我假设存在这样一种场景：美国在20世纪40年代末或50年代初抽身离开，就像第一次世界大战后发生的那样。
I mean, obviously, it didn't happen, and it didn't happen for very good structural deep-seated reasons. But the United States could have walked away. There could have been no Marshall Plan. There could have been communism in Italy or France. And then you're in a very different kind of ballgame, aren't you? I think so. I think especially, you know, I remember going to Italy in the late 70s, so let's say 77. And I remember seeing a red flag with a hammer and sickle flying from one
当然，这并没有发生，而且发生是有着非常好的结构性深层原因的。但美国本可以抽身离去。本可以没有马歇尔计划。意大利或法国本可能会出现共产主义。然后你就进入了一个完全不同的球局，不是吗？我想是的。尤其是，你知道，我记得在70年代末去过意大利，比方说77年。我记得看到一面印有锤子和镰刀的红旗从其中一栋
of the main buildings. And I just remember as an American during that era, just being shocked because you didn't expect communism to have such a foothold in a place like Italy. But your point is well taken. And I mean, imagine seeing, I i mean imagine it here's here's funny imagine it in the scandinavian countries i mean that's you can't even get your mind around a a communist norway or a communist sweden but think about how different that would have been well i mean actually the example finlandization i was about to say yes yes exactly that yeah a finlandization of more of Europe in which Sweden, Denmark, who knows, West Germany, Western border zone is… Well, that seems to be Putin's… I mean, that seems to be his ideal for much of Eastern Europe, certainly, and I would guess Scandinavia. Yeah, but given that Finland and Sweden are just about to…
主要建筑上飘扬。我只记得作为那个时代的美国人，我感到非常震惊，因为你没有料到共产主义会在意大利这样的地方有如此深厚的根基。但你的观点很对。我的意思是，想象一下看到……我的意思是，想象一下在斯堪的纳维亚国家——我的意思是，你甚至无法想象一个共产主义的挪威或共产主义的瑞典——但想想那会有多大不同。好吧，实际上，“芬兰化”这个例子——我正要说，是的，是的，完全正确，是的，更多欧洲的芬兰化，其中瑞典、丹麦，谁知道呢，西德，西部的边界地带是……好吧，这似乎是普京的……我的意思是，这似乎是他对东欧大部分地区（当然还有我猜测的斯堪的纳维亚）的理想状态。是的，但鉴于芬兰和瑞典马上就要……
I know, but he's miscalculated. But I would have thought that that was probably what he was hoping for to get from Ukraine if he conquered Ukraine. Well, that was his dream scenario, wasn't it? I think. Well, let me ask you guys, because now I've got you here. I'm going to turn the tables a little bit because I'm curious about your thoughts on this. But I mean, do you think he just, Putin in this sense, do you think he just miscalculated the attitudes that the former Soviet border states had in turn? I mean, we're reading a lot here and I never trust this sort of material for like you had said, we're going to have to wait 30 years to really find out, you know, all the ins and outs of what's going on right now. But the idea that he would be welcome, that the Russians would be
我知道，但他算错了。但我原本以为，如果他征服了乌克兰，这可能就是他希望从乌克兰得到的东西。好吧，那是他梦想中的场景，不是吗？我想是的。好吧，让我问问你们俩，既然我现在把你们找来了。我要稍微转换一下话题，因为我很好奇你们对此的想法。但是，我的意思是，你认为他——在这个意义上的普京——你认为他只是误判了前苏联边境国家反过来对他的态度吗？我的意思是，我们在这里读到了很多东西，我从来不信任这种材料，正如你所说，我们得等上30年才能真正弄清楚现在正在发生的一切的来龙去脉。但是那种他会受到欢迎，俄罗斯人会受到
welcomed with flowers the way that they were saying the United States would have been welcomed in Iraq. Is that just is that rose colored glasses? And is that something that's connected to his rose colored view of the old Soviet past? To me, right there, that's that's a huge miscalculation. And it looks like his strategy and tactics were inordinately based on on that view of the situation. What are your thoughts on that? As you say, it's very hard for us to know right now. Fog of war is terrible right now. Yeah, how the decision-making in the Kremlin works. But I mean, I don't know. I think the danger – I mean, I'm not the first person to have said this by any means.
鲜花欢迎的想法，就像他们说美国在伊拉克会受到欢迎那样？这只是玫瑰色的幻想吗？这是否与他对旧苏联过去的玫瑰色滤镜有关？对我来说，这绝对是一个巨大的误判。而且看起来他的战略和战术极其严重地建立在那样的局势观点之上。你们对此有什么看法？正如你们所说，我们现在很难真正知道。战争迷雾现在太浓了。是的，克里姆林宫的决策机制是如何运作的。但我的意思是，我不知道。我认为危险在于——我绝不是第一个这么说的人。
I've read it elsewhere. When you produce propaganda, the first people you persuade are yourselves, the producers of the propaganda and the stuff that he's come out with about you know the ukraine government are all neo-nazis but also the sort of the more babble sort of stuff where he says you know zelensky is a drug addict um they're all degenerates all this kind of sort of stuff i think he he said that so often that he actually genuinely ended up believing it. I think also, Dominic, don't you, that there was clearly a massive undercover war going on within Ukraine between rival security services. And my guess is that Putin thought that he had basically kind of gone through the Ukrainian military, the Ukrainian government,
我在别处读到过。当你制造宣传时，你首先说服的人就是你们自己，也就是宣传的制造者；而他关于乌克兰政府全都是新纳粹分子的言论，还有一些更胡言乱语的说法，比如他说泽连斯基是个瘾君子，他们全都是垮掉的一代，所有这类言论——我想他把这些话说得太多了，以至于他自己最后真的相信了。我也认为，多米尼克，难道你不觉得乌克兰内部的敌对安全部门之间显然正在进行一场大规模的地下战吗？我的猜测是，普京认为他基本上已经像蛀虫穿过木头一样，渗透了乌克兰军队、乌克兰政府、乌克兰公务员系统。
the Ukrainian civil service, like kind of wood through the Ukrainian military, the Ukrainian government, the Ukrainian civil service, like kind of woodworm. And that all he had to do was give it a knock and the whole structure would come tumbling down. But it's evident that there was a kind of an incredibly effective Ukrainian campaign of combating that. And I think that US and actually British intelligence as well probably seems to have played a very important role in kind of rolling up that campaign. And that is a campaign that also, of course, has been manifest in the Baltic States where the Russian minorities and, you know, in France where he was funding Marine Le Pen, in Italy where he has quite... I suspect that he, maybe because he's a man in a hurry and he wanted to believe it, maybe because his deputies were telling him what he wanted to hear, maybe because they genuinely believed that they had turned Ukraine rotten. But for all those reasons, I think that he overestimated how easy it would be. But I think there were lots of arguments, aren't there, that Russian nationalists are predisposed within the Ukraine as rotten, that they have a very particular relationship with Ukraine,
他觉得他只需要敲一下，整个结构就会轰然倒塌。但很明显，乌克兰发起了一场极其有效的反击行动。我认为美国以及英国的情报部门可能也在瓦解这场行动中发挥了非常重要的作用。而且这场行动当然也在波罗的海国家表现出来，那里的俄罗斯少数族裔……你知道的，在法国，他资助了玛丽娜·勒庞；在意大利，他有着相当……我怀疑，也许是因为他是一个急于求成的人，所以他愿意相信这一点；也许是因为他的下属只挑他爱听的话说；也许是因为他们真的相信他们已经把乌克兰搞烂了。但出于所有这些原因，我认为他高估了事情的容易程度。但我认为有很多争论，不是吗？俄罗斯民族主义者预先倾向于认为乌克兰已经腐败，他们与乌克兰有着非常独特的关系，
where they undervalue Ukrainian nationalism. They think it's invention, a concoction created by Western powers. I mean, it's really interesting how that, as soon as the invasion started to go badly and all those clips from Russian talk shows that circulate on social media, you know, you've probably seen, certainly, Tom, there's one in Britain that's been circulating where the guy, there was a Russian MP who's denouncing Britain,
他们低估了乌克兰的民族主义。他们认为这是一种发明，是西方大国捏造出来的虚假产物。我的意思是，真的很有趣，一旦入侵开始变得不顺利，社交媒体上流传的所有那些俄罗斯脱口秀的片段——你可能也看过了，汤姆，英国流传着这样一个片段，有个家伙，有个俄罗斯议员在谴责英国，
saying there's a, the double-headed, you probably won't have seen this, Dan, because it's something that matters to us but probably not to anybody else because it makes us seem very important this russian mp went on this show about three days ago and he said you know there's a double-headed dragon that controls world affairs and there's the united states and there's britain and as everybody knows britain is the more evil and conniving of the two heads. The glow of patriotic pride that we've all been feeling. Relevance, sweet relevance.
说有一个……双头龙控制着世界事务，一边是美国，另一边是英国，正如大家所知，英国是这两个头中更邪恶、更狡猾的一个。我们所有人内心都感受到了那种爱国主义自豪的光芒。存在感，甜美的存在感。
Yeah, sweet relevance. But he sort of ends this by saying, you know, what was it, go back to your island, catch your chip and fish and your foggy marshes. Eat your porridge and pray for your moss-covered queen yeah but um but obviously they lots of people in in russian nationalist circles think that britain the united states in particular nato have created a false national identity in ukraine and they merely needed to give that a push and it would just disintegrate
是的，甜美的存在感。但他以这样的话结束：“记不记得，回到你们的岛上去，去吃你们的炸鱼薯条和多雾的沼泽吧。吃你们的粥，为你们那长满青苔的女王祈祷吧。”是的，但是……但是显然，在俄罗斯民族主义圈子里有很多人认为英国、特别是美国和北约在乌克兰捏造了一个虚假的民族认同，他们只需要轻轻推一把，这个可怜的虚假造物就会彻底瓦解。
as the miserable kind of concoction that it was. And they completely underestimated the resilience of the Ukrainian ideal. I think also, don't you, that there has been a lurking sense in Russia that the West is decadent. And that's why Putin's been so keen on kind of transgender toilets and things like that.
而他们完全低估了乌克兰理想的韧性。我也认为，难道你不觉得俄罗斯一直有一种潜藏的观念，认为西方是颓废的吗？这就是为什么普京如此热衷于谈论跨性别厕所之类的事情。
But he's not, yeah, he's keen on talking. He's not keen on them. I mean, he's still keen. No, he's keen on talking about them. And I think in that sense, Zelensky is a kind, you know, was the absolute embodiment of that kind of decadence. To Putin, yeah.
但他并不是……是的，他热衷于谈论。他并非对它们感兴趣。我的意思是，他仍然热衷于……不，他热衷于谈论它们。而且我认为在这个意义上，泽连斯基某种程度上……你知道的，正是这种颓废的绝对化身。对普京来说，是的。
Who, you know, who'd been on television playing a grand piano with his penis. I mean, this is absolutely, he must've looked at that and thought the whole country is going to fold. You know, you can't help but notice that that's a very similar attitude toward Hitler's idea when he invaded the Soviet Union, that he wasn't going to have to conquer it lock, stock and barrel, but that like a rotten house, all you had to do was kick the door down, right? And by the way, as a veteran of the First World War, that's not a terrible example of maybe what happened to the Tsarist regime in the First World War. But let me point out, and I'm going to get a lot of maybe Americans upset with me for noticing the similarities,
你知道的，他曾经在电视上用自己的生殖器弹奏三角钢琴。我的意思是，这绝对是……他看到这个的时候一定觉得整个国家都要垮了。你知道，你不得不注意到，这与希特勒入侵苏联时的想法非常相似——他认为自己不需要彻底地、全盘地征服苏联，而是像一座腐烂的房子一样，你只要把门踢倒就行了，对吧？顺便说一句，作为一个一战老兵，这对于一战中沙皇政权的垮台来说，并不是一个糟糕的例子。但让我指出一点，而且我指出这些相似之处可能会惹恼很多美国人，
but if you change the word Nazi that the Russians are using for Ukraine and substitute communism, which, of course, the the all the things that you mentioned that he was looking at with Zelensky and that we've seen. I mean, they even brought up this this news story about cocaine and Zelensky. I mean, it's almost like there's a playbook of various things that you can, you know, not 19 things that you can cite and, you know, at least at least five of them to go to war and they're all the same variations of things that we've seen forever i mean machiavelli might have had the the original 19 and you just mad i don't know if mad libs means anything to you guys but you just sort of mad lib your way to uh to a war um a rationale and and and calling i mean the
但如果你把俄罗斯人用来形容乌克兰的“纳粹”一词换成“共产主义”——当然，你提到的他看待泽连斯基的所有那些方面以及我们所看到的现象。我的意思是，他们甚至还爆出了关于泽连斯基吸毒的新闻。我的意思是，这几乎就像有一本各种手段的剧本，你可以……你知道，不是19种你可以引用的战争借口，而你至少会挑选其中的5种来开战，它们全都是我们见过后世不衰的各种变体。我的意思是，马基雅维利可能拥有最初的19种借口，而你只是——我不知道“疯狂填词”对你们来说意味着什么——但你基本上就是用疯狂填词的方式来为一场战争拼凑借口、寻找合理性，并且宣称——我的意思是，
i mean the russian minister was it today or yesterday, calling Hitler, citing Jewish heritage? I mean, that whole it's so wickedly weird and wild and yet in a certain way predictable to people who know history that I can't help but notice that if if the shoe were on the other foot or the circumstance reversed, your country or my country might have figured out their own way to utilize those night into some of those 19 stereotypical war aims. Well, I mean, I've got no doubt that that the West is practicing propaganda. I mean, clearly, everybody does. I mean, we just have to accept that. And in a way and in a way, because ours is less obvious, it's probably more effective. Tom, let me throw another angle at you. There are those who would suggest that if we were not, that we would somehow be ceding the field to our adversaries, right? It's like I always tell people, if they say, do you think the US is involved in this? I would suggest that if they weren't, you would consider it somehow a dereliction of duty, right? That the reason that these agencies often exist is, and they wouldn't say they were there to
俄罗斯外长是今天还是昨天，称希特勒也有犹太血统？我的意思是，整个事情是如此邪恶、怪异、疯狂，但在懂历史的人看来却又是某种程度上可以预见的，以至于我不得不注意到，如果风水轮流转或者情况相反，你的国家或我的国家可能也会想出它们自己的方式来利用那19种典型的战争诉求中的一部分。好吧，我的意思是，毫无疑问，西方也在进行宣传。我的意思是，很显然每个人都在这样做。我的意思是，我们只能接受这一点。而且在某种程度上……而且在某种程度上，因为我们的宣传不那么显眼，所以可能更有效。汤姆，让我向你抛出另一个角度。有些人会暗示，如果我们不这样做，我们就会在某种程度上将阵地拱手让给我们的对手，对吧？就像我经常对人们说的那样，如果他们问：“你认为美国卷入其中了吗？”我会暗示，如果他们没有卷入，你反倒会认为这是某种程度上的失职，对吧？这些机构之所以经常存在，原因在于——而且他们不会说他们去那里是为了
change the scene. They would say that they were there to to change the scene. They would they would say that they were there to play defense against what the other side. Well, I think they did on this occasion. I mean, I think it's pretty clear that U.S. intelligence knew exactly what Putin's plans were and they revealed it at every stage. So that the whole kind of false flag narrative that Putin had obviously been preparing would be historical standpoint. Isn't that I mean, because we're getting some President Biden and I'm not a fan of any president in my lifetime, but but but he took some flack for this. But I think it was genius to be. And as you guys well know, if you decide to sacrifice means and methods in an intelligent situation, mean it must be worth it and to be able to say uh it would be the equivalent of being able to tell the world that hitler was dressing
改变局势。他们会说他们去那里是为了改变局势。他们会说他们去那里是为了对另一方采取防守态度。好吧，我认为他们在这次事件中确实这么做了。我的意思是，很明显，美国情报部门确切地知道了普京的计划，并且在每一个阶段都将其公之于众。因此，普京显然一直在准备的整个虚假旗帜叙事，从历史的角度来看——难道这不是……我的意思是，因为我们看到拜登总统——我不是我生任何一位总统的粉丝，但他因此受到了一些批评。但我认为他的做法简直是天才。正如你们很清楚的那样，如果你决定牺牲情报工作中的手段和方法，这意味着它一定值得这样做，而且能够做到这一点——这就相当于能够向全世界宣布希特勒正在让
wehrmacht soldiers in polish uniforms to have them fight i mean it's brilliant if you think about it's almost like like announcing their chess move before they make it exactly i thought it was it's and i can't think actually of many examples in the history i can't either well when it's ever been done yeah it's brilliant it's going to many examples in the history. I can't either. When it's ever been done. Yeah. It's going to go down in the annals of military history as something worth noting anyway. We've got two more. Any two more?
国防军士兵穿上波兰军服让他们去战斗。我的意思是，如果你仔细想想，这太绝了，这几乎就像是在对手做出下一步棋之前就提前宣布他们的棋步一样。完全是这样，我觉得这简直是……而且我其实想不出历史上有多少这样的例子。我也想不出来。什么时候有过这样的先例？是的，这太绝了。无论如何，这注定要载入军事史册，成为值得注意的一笔。我们还有两个。还有其他的吗？
We'll get to five hours, guys. You'll get to five and a half hours on this. I know. You're just getting into your seat. Yeah. I'm finally warmed up. Exactly. But hold on.
我们甚至能聊满五个小时，伙们。你们在这个话题上能聊五个半小时。我知道。你们才刚刚进入状态。是的。我终于热身完毕了。完全正确。但是等等。
But in your podcast, you're just talking to yourself. Yeah. Well, I have a lot of good counterpoints. No, I disagree with myself. I'm wrong. I think you could do five hours on your own, Tom. No, I couldn't. I need you, Dominic.
不过在你的播客里，你其实是在自言自语。是的。嗯，我有很多很好的反驳观点。不，我反驳我自己。我错了。我觉得你自己一个人就能聊五个小时，汤姆。不，我不能。我需要你，多米尼克。
You're so kind. The grit that produces the pearl. I love that. Okay, so this is the final. This is a crucial question. Dan, you need to choose bodyguards. Who would you choose to serve as your bodyguards a spartans b vikings or c samurai so spartans vikings or samurai they all have something to offer but in this case i'm going to go with samurai i think that uh just from a
你太好了。孕育珍珠的砂砾。我喜欢这样。好吧，这是最后一个问题。这是一个至关重要的问题。丹，你需要选择保镖。你会选择谁来做你的保镖：A.斯巴达人，B.维京人，还是C.武士？所以是斯巴达人、维京人还是武士？他们每个人都有其过人之处，但在这种情况下，我要选武士。我认为……仅从
loyalty standpoint i think i would trust them more although that you know i mean i'm sure some japanese history person's gonna say well that would be a dumb move because of blah, blah, blah. But I certainly think that Vikings and Spartans would have probably more of an ability. I don't know. I think samurai would be the way I would go. Short answer. And that's a good answer. I was tempted by Vikings, Tom, because of course, that huge business about oaths with Vikings. But then if you read the sagas, they're full of people staying overnight at somebody's house who lops off their head and yeah i think vikings would be a terrible terrible choice i think that's a yeah i mean what if they're berserkers and they
忠诚的角度来看，我觉得我更信任他们——尽管（我知道）肯定会有某个日本历史学者跳出来说：“这会是个愚蠢的举动，因为巴拉巴拉巴拉。”但我确信，维京人和斯巴达人在能力上可能更强……我不知道。我觉得武士会是我的选择。简短的回答。这是一个很好的回答。汤姆，我一度被维京人吸引，当然是因为维京人那种关于誓言的庞大体系。但后来如果你读过那些萨迦传奇，就会发现里面到处都是那些在别人家里过夜却把人家脑袋砍下来的家伙……是的，我觉得维京人会是一个糟糕透顶的选择。我觉得这是一个……我的意思是，如果他们是狂战士，然后
just you know start taking their clothes off i mean you wouldn't want that would you it'd be very embarrassing depends on the social occasion you. You're going out to a restaurant and suddenly your bodyguards are chewing the table and stuff. What are Spartans? Why are you not choosing Spartans? Well, I think Spartans would be very, very good, but you'd have to ask their motivation because Spartans are motivated by the collective, the idea of the collective. Would they be as committed to looking after you as a private individual? Well, and if you give them a reason to argue, if you give them a reason to make those distinctions, you're already probably farther along in terms of worry as a leader about your bodyguard than you might be with the samurai who might not get to that level of questioning. You know, I think I think samurai every time, because Dan, as you say, I mean, their whole ethos is of loyalty.
他们……你知道的，突然开始脱衣服怎么办？我的意思是，你不会希望那样发生吧，那会非常尴尬的。这取决于社交场合。你正要去餐馆吃饭，突然你的保镖开始啃桌子之类的。斯巴达人怎么样？为什么你不选斯巴达人？好吧，我觉得斯巴达人会非常非常优秀，但你得去探究他们的动机，因为斯巴达人受集体主义、集体观念的驱动。他们会像照顾一个普通平民那样全心全意地照顾你吗？而且，如果你给他们一个争论的理由，如果你给他们一个做出这种区分的理由，作为一个领导者，你在担心保镖这件事上，可能已经比选择那些可能不会达到那种质疑层面的武士走得更远了。你知道，我觉得……我每次都会选武士，因为丹，正如你所说，我的意思是，他们的整个精神内核就是忠诚。
Well, I'm sure there's some examples where that would work against you, but I think less. Of course. But you are the kind of enlightened person who's going for germ theory. So, you know, if they fall sick, you can look after them and they'll absolutely love you. There you go. And I want to say that not choosing Vikings as a fan of Alfred the Great, there might be a little bit of prejudice involved in that decision also. That's fine. Let's acknowledge your bias. We all have prejudice.
好吧，我确信在某些情况下这会适得其反，但我认为这种情况较少。当然。但你是一个接受了细菌学说的开明人士，所以，你知道，如果他们生病了，你可以照顾他们，他们会绝对爱死你的。就是这样。我想说的是，作为一个阿尔弗雷德大帝的粉丝而不选择维京人，那个决定中可能也包含了一点点偏见。没关系。让我们承认你的偏见。我们都有偏见。
Am I not right in thinking the Vikings are the only people in that multiple choice? Who actually were bodyguards. Who were hired bodyguards for a foreign power. Which is to say they were. Yeah, right. So that's Harold Hardrada, friend of the show. Yes. He was a very successful bodyguard, wasn't he?
难道我没记错的话，在那个多选题里，维京人是唯一真正充当过保镖的人吗？他们曾是为外国势力雇佣的保镖。也就是说，他们确实是。是的，没错。所以那是哈罗德·哈德拉达，节目的老朋友。是的，他是个非常成功的保镖，对吧？
Yes, but they would just go around graffitiing your house. They did leave graffiti, didn't they? Yes, you wouldn't want that. I think you could rely on the samurai not to do that. The samurai would beautiful writing. All people are not telling me that you would reject Viking graffiti in your house. Some runes on the side of your house. I would quite like that.
是的，但他们会到处在你的房子上乱涂乱画。他们确实留下了涂鸦，对吧？是的，你不会希望那样的。我想你可以信赖武士不会做那种事。武士会有美丽的字迹。大家并不是在告诉我你会拒绝维京人在你家里涂鸦吧。在你的房子侧面写上一些卢恩文字。我其实挺喜欢那样的。
We all would. I would actually go for Spartans just because I'd love the idea of having Spartans. But if I wanted to stay alive, I'd probably go for Samurai. Okay. Anyway, important. So those are nine of the ten questions. These are the really big questions. We have one last big historical question.
我们所有人都会。我其实会选斯巴达人，仅仅因为我喜欢拥有斯巴达人的这种想法。但如果我想保住性命，我可能会选武士。好吧。无论如何，很重要。所以那是十个问题中的九个。这些都是真正的大问题。我们还有一个最后的重大历史问题。
So this is the question that destroys our podcast, isn't it, Tom? If Dan answers it wrong, we have to hang up our boots. All right. Well, no. No pressure. I don't think so. Well, let's see. And I'd be interested to actually know what Tom thinks about this as well.
所以这就是那个毁掉我们播客的问题，对吧，汤姆？如果丹答错了，我们就得挂靴不干了。好吧。嗯，不。没有压力。我不这么认为。好吧，让我们拭目以待。而且我也很想知道汤姆对此有什么看法。
So, Dan, can we ever really know what happened in the past? Oh, there was a great quote in Pierre Briand's book on the Persians. He quoted somebody else, and I don't remember who it was, but the great line was, even if it's not true, you have to believe ancient history. And I love that line because it's so summed up to me that the problem, right? I mean, the choice is to not believe any of it, in which case you're blind or believe it and recognize that there's all kinds of stuff that you can't get your mind around in terms of truth. I would say rephrase the question so I answer it properly. It's not a yes or no answer, is it? Because I'm
那么，丹，我们能真正了解过去发生过的事情吗？哦，皮埃尔·布里安关于波斯人的书里有一句很棒的名言。他引用了别人的话，我不记得是谁说的了，但那句精彩的话是：“即使这不是真的，你也必须相信古代历史。”我太喜欢这句话了，因为它对我而言完美地概括了问题所在，对吧？我的意思是，要么选择什么都不信，那样的话你就是盲目的；要么选择相信它，并认识到有各种各样的事情你在真相层面是无法理清的。我会重新措辞这个问题，以便我能正确回答。这不是一个非黑即白的是非题，对吧？因为我
going to say that the earlier you go, the harder it is to answer that question. And conversely, the more recent you go, it's also very hard to answer that question. I think it's easier for us to know about the late 1800s, early to mid 1900s, maybe maybe not even mid than it is to know either Pierre Briand's Persian era or our current era right this minute for obvious reasons. So, yeah, I'm going to say, yes, you know more than you don't. I mean, if you didn't know any of the stuff about the ancient Greeks because you threw it out because there was a whole bunch of nonsense mixed in, you'd be the poorer for it, I would think. Essentially, every book I've written has been about this question
要说的是，你离得越早，回答这个问题就越难。反过来说，你离现代越近，回答这个问题其实也很难。我认为比起皮埃尔·布里安的波斯时代或此时此刻我们当前的时代，出于显而易见的原因，我们要了解19世纪末、20世纪初到中期——也许甚至都不到中期——的历史要更容易一些。所以，是的，我要说的是，是的，你知道的比你不知道的要多。我的意思是，如果你因为里面掺杂了一堆胡言乱语就把关于古希腊的所有东西都扔掉一无所知，那你的人生将会因此变得更加贫乏，我想是这样的。从本质上讲，我写过的每一本书都是围绕着这个问题的，
because I write about periods where the evidence is often very, very – well, do you know, often what we call the primary sources are often crafted as literature. question because i write about periods where the evidence is often very very um well it's well do you know often the prime what we call the primary sources are often crafted as literature yeah they're herodotus herodotus or livy or tacitus my god he's a gossip colonist yeah so my feeling is is that that the way that the past is mediated to us understanding that is is understanding the past is mediated to us, understanding that is understanding the past. We can know, for instance, that the Romans saw the world in a certain way that is not our way. And that the way that historians or inscriptions or whatever is preserved, they may not tell us absolutely pure objective facts that we can nail down and say, yes, this definitely happened.
因为我写的时期，证据往往非常非常……好吧，你知道的，通常我们称之为一手史料的东西，往往都被精心雕琢成了文学作品。问题，因为我写的是那些证据往往非常非常……嗯，好吧，你知道的，通常情况下，那些我们称之为一手史料的东西，往往被加工成了文学作品。是的，它们是希罗多德、李维或者塔西佗——天哪，他是个爱八卦的专栏作家。是的，所以我的感觉是，过去是如何向我们呈现的，理解这一点……理解过去是如何向我们呈现的，就是在理解过去。例如，我们可以知道，罗马人看待世界的方式与我们的方式不同。而且，无论历史学家、铭文还是其他被保存下来的东西，它们可能并没有告诉我们绝对纯粹的、我们可以钉死并说“是的，这绝对发生了”的客观事实。
But what they do tell us is that this is the expression of a particular way of seeing and understanding the world. And I think we can get a handle on that. But for example, OK, that's fine. That's understanding how they understood the world. Which is also, Dominic, why I moved on to christianity and islam because i because i felt on safer but no because i came to realize that that our way of seeing the world is not neutral and that it's kind of bred of particular traditions and inheritance of tradition just as much as as tacitus or herodotus had Tom, what if you had Carthaginian sources to pit against the Roman ones? Well, then our understanding of what happened in the past would become richer.
但它们真正告诉我们的是，这是某种特定的看待和理解世界的方式的表达。我认为我们能够掌握这一点。但是，比如说，好吧，这没问题。那是理解他们是如何理解世界的。这也是为什么，多米尼克，我转向了基督教和伊斯兰教的研究，因为我觉得在那种领域更安全……不，因为我逐渐意识到，我们看待世界的方式并不是中立的，它同样孕育自特定的传统和传统的传承，就像塔西佗或希罗多德那样。汤姆，如果你有迦太基的史料来与罗马的史料相对抗呢？好吧，那么我们对过去发生的事情的理解就会变得更加丰富。
But also maybe less stable. We can understand what happened in the Punic Wars to the degree that we can understand how the Romans saw it. When we try and work out how the Carthaginians understood what they were living through, we're looking through a glass darkly. And we're looking through the glass darkly because of the result of that war. So that is a part of the truth of the war. The fact that we don't know what the Carthaginians thought by and large is a part of the reality that we're studying, if that makes sense. But let's take a character that you two have both, you know, you're both
但同时也可能变得不那么稳定。我们在罗马人看待布匿战争的程度上去理解它发生了什么。当我们试图弄清楚迦太基人如何理解他们所经历的事情时，我们就像是在透过阴暗的玻璃看世界。而我们之所以透过阴暗的玻璃看世界，正是那场战争结局的结果。所以这也是战争真实性的一部分。总的来说，我们不知道迦太基人是怎么想的，这一事实构成了我们正在研究的现实的一部分，如果这说得通的话。但让我们以一个你们俩都——你知道的，你们都
very interested in. You've both, in your case, Dan talked a lot about and Tom written about Julius Caesar. So much of what we know about Julius Caesar is based on a handful of sources. And those stories are repeated. Some of those sources are Caesar himself, too. No, I would say that relative to other great figures, I mean, certainly Alexander. Yeah, but Alexander, you're talking about four sources. Exactly, exactly. But actually, we know quite a lot about Caesar.
非常感兴趣的人物为例。你们俩——在你的例子中，丹谈论了很多关于尤利乌斯·凯撒的事，而汤姆也写过关于他的书。我们对尤利乌斯·凯撒的了解，有很大一部分是基于少数几份史料。而且这些故事被反复讲述。其中一些史料甚至就来自凯撒本人。不，我会说，与其他伟人相比——当然，亚历山大大帝……是的，但说到亚历山大，你谈论的只有四份史料。确切地说，完全正确。但实际上，我们对凯撒了解得相当多。
But not by the standards of ancient history, not by the standards of any modern thing. Yeah, but we have his writings. We have writings about him in actually voluminous amounts from Cicero, which is very, very unusual. We have biographies. We actually have quite a lot of material and we have enough, I think, to get a sense of his character, his personality, what he was about. We don't know some fairly fundamental things about his life. That's absolutely true. But I think we know enough about him to arrive at an approximation of what he was doing. Partly, not just because we have facts about Caesar personally, but because we have the period of Roman history in which he lived is the most
但按照古代历史的标准、按照任何现代事物的标准来看，并非如此。是的，但我们有他的著作。我们有关于他的、实际上数量极其庞大的来自西塞罗的著作，这非常非常罕见。我们有传记。我们实际上有相当多的材料，而且我认为，我们有足够的材料来大致了解他的性格、他的个性以及他是个什么样的人。对于他生活中的一些相当基础的事情，我们确实一无所知。这绝对是真的。但我认为我们对他的了解已经足够让我们大致推断出他在做什么。部分原因不仅是因为我们有关于凯撒本人的事实，还因为他生活的那个时期的罗马历史是整个古代历史中记载最丰富的。
richly documented in the whole of ancient history. And therefore we can situate him in a context that makes sense of the kind of person that he was. What about a later figure then, like Caligula or Nero, who we've also talked about in this podcast? Caligula, I think is very difficult. I mean, everything that we all know about Caligula, all the stories, picks up the seashells on the beach, the console, his horse, all that stuff. I do not know what happened, what that was about. I've read every theory there is, and none of them make sense.
因此，我们可以将他置于一个能够合理解释他那类人的语境中。那么后来的某个历史人物呢，比如卡利古拉或尼禄，我们在这次播客中也讨论过他们？卡利古拉，我认为非常困难。我的意思是，我们所有人对卡利古拉的了解，所有的故事——在海滩上捡贝壳、执政官、他的马，所有这些东西。我不知道到底发生了什么，那到底是怎么回事。我看过所有的理论，没有一个说得通的。
So I just don't know what that whole, you know, Caligula getting his soldiers to pick up shells. But let's add another aspect to this that we should all be aware of. I just don't know what that whole, you know, clearly getting his soldiers to pick up shells. But let's let's let's add another aspect to this that we should all be aware of. I mean, Alexander the Great famously went around with what we would call today a paid for personal press corps. Right. So these are people who are taking an active interest in trying to manipulate how future generations will view them. And the funny thing is, when you're so bereft of sources that you only oftentimes have those kinds of sources or sources that may be polluted by those kinds of things, it makes it even harder. It's just like, you know, trying to figure out Augustus Caesar's situation when you know darn well that if somebody during his lifetime wrote something nasty, they might not be around the next day. So it's difficult, obviously,
所以我只是不知道整个事情……你知道的，卡利古拉让他的士兵去捡贝壳。但让我们为之增添另一个我们都应该意识到的层面。我只是不知道整件事……你知道的，很明显让士兵去捡贝壳。但让我们……让我们……让我们为之增添另一个我们都应该意识到的层面。我的意思是，亚历山大大帝曾带着我们今天所说的“付费个人媒体团”到处走，这很有名。对吧？所以这些人对试图操纵后代如何看待他们有着积极的兴趣。有趣的是，当你如此缺乏史料，以至于你往往只有那种类型的史料，或者被那种东西污染了的史料时，这会让情况变得更加困难。这就像……你知道的，当你明知如果有人在奥古斯都·凯撒生前写了哪怕一点坏话，他们第二天可能就人间蒸发了的时候，你却还要去弄清楚奥古斯都·凯撒的处境。所以这显然是很困难的。
it's part of the job, isn't it, to tease all that stuff out if you can. Yeah, absolutely. But I think the fact that Alexander was the kind of person who did employ people to follow around writing him up is a part of what we know. Yes, good point. So, and we know that his particular understanding of fame and undying glory, for instance, is influenced by Homer and the model of Achilles. So we know that as well. So in a sense, what we can know, I suppose, is how treacherous the standards of objectivity in vast stretches of history are. But that in a sense, you to surrender to to accepting that what we are studying is
把所有那些东西尽可能地挖掘出来，这也是工作的一部分，不是吗？对，完全是。但我觉得，亚历山大恰恰是那种会雇人跟在自己后面把他的事迹写下来的人，这也是我们所了解的情况的一部分。是的，说得好。所以，而且我们知道，他对名声和永恒荣耀的特定理解，举例来说，是受到荷马以及阿喀琉斯这一模范的影响。所以我们对这一点也很清楚。因此从某种意义上说，我认为我们所能知道的，是历史中漫长岁月中客观性的标准是多么不可靠。但从某种意义上说，你得屈服于并接受我们正在研究的东西
is never going to be objective in the way that that a 21st century historian would want it to be and i think it can't be because they are situated in entirely different contexts they have entirely different understandings of who they are, what they're about, what the very nature of history is. But large numbers of, as you'll know from reading Briand, the Persians didn't have an understanding of history in that way. Which is why you have the disbalance between, say, what the Persian wars, we only have records from the Greeks. Or Alexander, we only have records from the Macedonian side. Sounds like what you're saying is even if it's not true, you have to believe ancient history.
永远不可能具备21世纪的历史学家所希望的那种客观性，而且我认为它不可能做到这一点，因为他们身处完全不同的语境中，他们对我是谁、我是做什么的、历史的本质到底是什么，有着完全不同的理解。但是正如你从阅读布里昂的书中所知道的那样，大量波斯人并没有那样理解历史。这就是为什么会出现这种不对称，比方说，波斯战争我们只有希腊方面的记录。或者亚历山大，我们只拥有马其顿方面的记录。听起来你的意思是，即使它不是真的，你也必须相信古代历史。
Well, that's it. Well, but what is truth? What is truth, I guess. Yeah, well, what is truth? But also, I mean, what actually Dan is putting his finger on, Tom, is that in a previous podcast, you identified yourself, didn't you, as a cakist, rather like Boris Johnson. So you believe in having your cake and eating it.
嗯，就是这样。好吧，但什么是真相？我想，什么是真相？是的，好吧，什么是真相？不过还有，我的意思是，汤姆，丹实际上指出的一点是，在之前的播客中，你曾把自己定义为一个“蛋糕主义者”，有点像鲍里斯·约翰逊。所以你主张鱼与熊掌兼得。
I didn't know what a cakist was. I was feeling like an idiot. I'm going, what's a cakist? No, so a cakist is somebody who says, well, the sources are very dodgy, depend very much on literary formulas. However, I will now spend the next 10 pages telling you this fantastic story. Yes, yes. But I just –
我当时都不知道什么是“蛋糕主义者”。我感觉自己像个傻子。我在想，什么是蛋糕主义者？不，所以“蛋糕主义者”是指那种人，他说，嗯，这些资料非常不可靠，很大程度上依赖于文学套路。然而，我接下来要花10页的篇幅来给你讲这个精彩的故事。对，对。但我只是——
Wait, that's how I start every podcast so you know so i would i would say if that that by and large if i'm writing about people who believe in angels i will include angels within the narrative but i will make it clear yeah that that i don't necessarily believe in angels i remember once but the belief in angels is an important part of the world in which these characters live in i remember once doing when i did um when i was an undergraduate doing by zantine history and talking to my tutor and he was saying we were talking about this icon that had won a siege or something it had been the crucial factor in this siege the icon had displayed used its power and the attackers had been driven away and it sort of became obvious in the course of the tutorial that we were talking slightly across purposes because i was talking as if the icon was obviously a fiction and this hadn't
等等，我每个播客都是这样开场的，所以你知道的。所以我会说，大体上如果我写的人物相信天使，我会在叙事中把天使也写进去，但我会明确表示，是的，我本人不一定相信天使。我记得有一次，当我在读本科时研究拜占庭历史，跟我的导师交谈，我们在讨论某个曾赢得过一场围城战之类的圣像，它曾是那场围城战中的关键因素，那个圣像展现并运用了它的力量，把进攻者给击退了。在辅导讨论的过程中，情况变得有点明朗：我们有点各说各话，因为我说话的语气好像那个圣像显然是虚构的，这并没有
happened and he said well how do you know it didn't happen i mean the sources say the icon you know are you do you know better and i exactly well that's exactly i mean that's difficult to be writing about that's like our old friend um ptolemy and his talking snakes in the desert tom when they're lost on the way to the or of Siwa. And Arian says, the talking snakes showed Alexander the way. And Ptolemy, I got this story from Ptolemy and he's a king and he wouldn't lie. But Dominic, I think it also plays back to something we were talking earlier about how do you frame George Washington or Churchill? In a sense, you have to place them in the context in which they live. That is kind
发生过。而他说，嗯，你凭什么知道它没有发生？我的意思是，资料上说那个圣像，你知道的，难道你知道得比它们还清楚？我完全——是的，那确实很难写。这就像我们的老朋友托勒密和他在沙漠里遇到的会说话的蛇一样，汤姆，当他们在去锡瓦绿洲的路上迷路时。阿里安说，会说话的蛇给亚历山大指了路。而托勒密——这个故事我是从托勒密那里听来的，他是个国王，他不会撒谎。但多米尼克，我觉得这也呼应了我们之前讨论的一个话题：你该如何去解读乔治·华盛顿或丘吉尔？从某种意义上说，你必须把他们置于他们所处的时代背景中。
of the reality. That's part of the reality. That's part of the truth. Yeah. Yeah, but it's not what a lot of historians do though, is it? Because a lot of historians' instinct is to take people sort of out of the mock heroic context that they might have thought themselves in, Churchill is a good example, and to subject them to the sort of bright, forensic lights of modernity, don't you think? Yes, but I remember when I wrote a book about the origins of Islam, and it rapidly became clear to me that the stories told by Muslims about the life of Muhammad and the origins of the Quran and so on were not to be trusted as records of what I would recognize as fact. And yet they created their own reality. And that reality- I was just going to say that, yes.
这就是现实的一部分。那是现实的一部分。那是真相的一部分。对。是的，但这并不是许多历史学家所做的事情，不是吗？因为许多历史学家的本能是把人们从那种他们自己可能认为置身其中的虚假英雄主义语境中剥离出来——丘吉尔就是一个很好的例子——然后把他们置于现代明亮、严密审视的聚光灯下，你不觉得吗？是的，但还记得当我写一本关于伊斯兰教起源的书时，我很快就清楚地意识到，穆斯林讲述的关于穆罕默德生平和古兰经起源等方面的故事，是不能当作我所认知的“事实”记录来信任的。然而他们创造了自己的现实。而那个现实——我正要说这个，是的。
You know, it has changed the world. Yes. And I remember also talking about this and a Muslim in the audience saying, well, you know, on what basis are you saying it's not true? Because, you know, it's not like you're being neutral. Your perspective is just as, you know, you don't believe in God. You don't believe in the God that I believe in. But your disbelief is just as much a, that it if enough people believe it for long enough it creates its own reality as if as if it doesn't matter so much whether it actually happened or not because that didn't influence all the people that were 100 sure it did happen and acted on that basis i can't actually remember what dan's answer was now it seems so long ago um your answer was
你知道，它改变了世界。是的。我也记得讨论过这个，台下一个穆斯林说，嗯，你知道的，你凭什么说它不是真的？因为，你知道的，你并不是保持中立。你的视角同样也，你知道的，你不相信上帝。你不相信我所相信的上帝。但你的不信同样也是一种……如果足够多的人长期坚信它，它就会创造出它自己的现实，就好像它是否真的发生过已经没那么重要了，因为这不会影响到那些确信它发生过并据此行事的人。我实际上记不清当时丹的回答是什么了，现在感觉那是好久以前的事了。嗯，你的回答是
yes you do think was that answer yes? We can know? Yes, yes. Yes, I think so. Okay, brilliant. Well, that's a relief because we can continue our history podcast. No, otherwise we'd have to cancel it. I asked science historian James Burke that same question, and he answered yes also. Excellent.
对，你觉得是那个回答吗？我们能知道吗？对，对。是的，我想是的。好的，太棒了。好吧，这真是一种解脱，因为我们可以继续我们的历史播客了。不然的话我们得把它取消了。我问过科学史学家詹姆斯·伯克同样的问题，他的回答也是“是”。太好了。
He must be right then. He was right on everything. That's what I was asserting, yes. Wonderful. So, Dan, we haven't quite made five hours, but we have gone on. That's not my fault,
那他肯定是对的咯。他在所有事情上都是对的。这就是我当时所坚持的，是的。太棒了。所以，丹，我们虽然还没满五个小时，但确实聊了很久。这不是我的错，
Dominic. That's not my fault. We have gone on exactly an hour longer than we were expecting to, which is a sign, I think, of a good conversation. I hope so. So thank you so much for,
多米尼克。这不是我的错。我们比预期整整多聊了一个小时，我认为这是一场好对话的标志。我希望如此。所以非常感谢你，
for coming on the rest is history. It's great to, we have had other podcasters on from time to time, Tom, but I don't think we've ever had people with the who've who've gone past the five hour mark on their own podcast never so you guys this was actually a great honor and i'm a big fan so thank you for having me on i appreciate it thank you and tom is all ours tom restrained himself from doing his american accent
来到“历史其余部分”。很高兴——我们时不时也会请其他播客的主播来，汤姆，但我想我们从来没有请过在他们自己的播客里聊过整整五个小时的人。从来没有。所以你们两位，这其实是一个巨大的荣誉，我是你们的超级粉丝，所以感谢你们邀请我来，我很感激。谢谢你。而汤姆全是我们的，汤姆克制住了自己，没有用他的美国口音
which is i mean if he did it with you, you'd have, well, you'd have run screaming out into the night. You would have done, yeah. So I'm not going to. We can all play that game. So you guys are just as fortunate I didn't do one of my British accents. All right. Brilliant. Well, thank you all for listening.
也就是——我的意思是，如果他在你面前用那个口音，你大概会吓得尖叫着逃进夜里。你确实会这么做的，对吧。所以我不会这么做。我们都可以玩这个游戏。所以你们也很幸运，我没有用我的英国口音。好吧。太棒了。好吧，谢谢大家的收听。
And thank you again to Dan Carlin from Hardcore History for coming on the show. And we'll see you all next time. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
再次感谢来自《硬核历史》的丹·卡林来到节目中。我们下次节目再见。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告体验以及进入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦的每周必看节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集以及提前购买现场活动门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。